THE WEDNESDAY JUNE THE TWENTIETH
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN MEETING OF
THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE --
DON'T MOVE EVEN IF I DON'T THINK
WE EVEN OF MEMBERS FOR A QUORUM
THIS TIMING WHEN ASKED FOR ALL
MEMBERS --
TO COME TO ROOM FOUR FOUR SEVEN
SO THAT WE CAN SEATS ESTABLISH
QUORUM BUT IN THE ABSENCE OF ONE
WE WILL BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE
I KNOW THAT THE FOR SENATOR HAS
A NINE THIRTY SPECIAL ORDER
ELSEWHERE SO WANT TO US START
THE DISCUSSION HERE.
AND WITH THAT.
SENATOR WINNER WHEN YOU'RE READY.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
THANK YOU TO YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFFER.
OUT WORKING WITH US ON S. B. IT --
TWENTY EIGHT AND I DO --
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES ARE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT TO THE BILL
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT --
SP TWENTY A I WILL STRENGTHEN --
THERE GREEN ARE THE REASON A
HOUSING NEEDS ASSESSMENT --
TO MAKE IT --
A MORE POWERFUL TOOL OPETH STATE
TO ENFORCE OUR HOUSING LAWS AND
FAIR SHARE.
OUR PRINCIPLES --
AS YOU KNOW. THREE AND A HALF
MILLION HOMES WHICH IS EQUAL TO
THE HOUSING DEFICIT IN THE OTHER
FORTY NINE STATES --
COMBINED --
THIS DEFICIT IS AT ALL INCOME
LEVELS IS A MARKET RATE AND IT
IS PARTICULARLY ACUTE AT LOW AND
VERY LOW INCOME.
A LEVELS WHERE WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE NOT BEING PUSHED IN THE
HOMELESSNESS WORKING FAMILIES
WHO WERE FORCED TO COMMUTE HOURS
AND HOURS TO WORKING PEOPLE.
WHO ARE LEAVING THE STATE
ENTIRELY AND CHILDREN WHO GO TO
COLLEGE AND I CAN'T AFFORD TO
MOVE BACK IN THE TOWN WHERE THEY?
GREW UP AND LET'S HAVE THAT IN
THEIR PARENTS BASEMENT SO THIS
IS AN EXTREME ISSUE THAT.
HARMS OUR ECONOMY OUR
ENVIRONMENT OUR STATE'S
DIVERSITY --
OUR HEALTH OUR QUALITY OF LIFE --
AND STRENGTHENING RENA THIS ONE
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT COMMUNITIES ARE ARE.
CREATING THEIR FAIR SHARE OF
HOUSING --
THAT IT'S EQUITABLE --
AND THAT --
HEALTH IN ALL INCOME LEVELS IS
BEING ZONED FOR AND ONLY A MOVE
FORWARD S. B. THIRTY FIVE LAST
YEAR THAT WAS BY THE ONE THING
THAT EVERYONE AGREED ON THAT
RENO NEEDED A LOT OF HELP --
AND THERE ARE SOME EXTREME
DISPARITIES ON FOR EXAMPLE --
IN -- LOS
ANGELES COUNTY --
REDONDO BEACH WAS ALLOCATED
ABOUT FOURTEEN HUNDRED UNITS OF
HOUSING OVER NEED YOUR ARENA
CYCLE ITS NEIGHBORS.
SIMILAR POPULATION HERMOSA BEACH
MANHATTAN BEACH --
WERE AYE RESPECTIVELY ALLOCATED
TO UNITS AND THIRTY SEVEN UNITS
BEVERLY HILLS WAS ALLOCATED TO
UNITS OVER AN EIGHT YEAR PERIOD --
IT SO I DID SOMETHING WRONG.
I'M SB.
TWENTY EIGHT ON THOSE A FEW
THINGS ON PURPOSE TO PROVIDE
SPECIFIC GUIDANCE TO A CD.
ON HOW TO CALCULATE BUT BACKLOG
OF EXISTING HOUSING NEED REASON
BY REASON BY INTEGRATING DATA
ABOUT THEY CAN SEE RAY
OVERCROWDING AND HOUSING COSTS
BURDEN.
SO WE CAN START DIGGING OUT OF A
MASSIVE DEFICIT WE FACE
[inaudible]
I ALSO [inaudible]
REQUIRES COMMUNITIES AS PART OF
THE RINA AND HOUSING ON THE
PROCESS.
I TWO ZONE FOR ONE HUNDRED AND
25% OF THEIR GREEN ALLOCATION --
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE A SHOT OF HITTING
A 100%.
I WE STARTED OUT OF THE BILL
2100% IT'S NOW A 125% AYE AND
THE CHALLENGES THATIF A
COMMUNITY IS JONES FOR EXACTLY
1100% OF THE ARENA.
THERE ARE MANY REASONS WHY OF
THE PROJECT.
X. Y. Z. PROJECT MAY NOT HAVE
BEEN OR MIGHT BE DELAYED OR
MIGHT END UP PRODUCING FEWER
UNITS AND AND THAT ITS OWN.
FOR AYE SO YOU'RE SETTING
YOURSELF UP NEVER TO HIT A 100%
AYE IF YOU ONLY ZONE FOR HUNTER
PRESENTS A ONE TWENTY FIVE WILL
LEAST --
GIVE US A SHOT AT HITTING 100% --
AND THEN --
IN TERMS OF IF GROWTH IN PAINFUL
AREA SO IT REQUIRES ON THE
COUNCIL GOVERNMENTS OUGHT TO
FOCUS ON ON GROWTH AND HIGH
OPPORTUNITY AREAS WITH THE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION.
A LOT OF THE BILL ALSO EXCEPT TO
GUARD RAILS --
AROUND WHEN THE STATE ALLOCATES
TO EACH REGION THIS IS HOW MANY
UNITS YOUR REGION IS REQUIRED TO
PRODUCE A RIGHT NOW IT BECOMES A
POLITICAL FOOD FIGHT IN TERMS OF
HOW.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE DISTRIBUTED
WITH AND THE REASON TO
INDIVIDUAL CITIES THAT'S HOW WE
END UP WITH SOME OF THESE
DISPARITIES.
OF THE BILL WILL REQUIRE A MUCH
MORE -- DATA
DRIVEN APPROACH IN TERMS OF
THOSE INTERNAL REGIONAL --
ALLOCATIONS OF HOUSING GOING TO
THANK THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP BAY AREA
COUNCIL FOR CO SPONSORING THE
BILL -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND WITH ME TODAY ARE MICHAEL
LANE FROM THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
AND LESS SHEPHERD FROM SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS HAVE
BLACK SHEPHERD REPRESENTING THAT
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP.
THE LEADERSHIP GROUP JOINTLY
RELEASED A REPORT CALLED THE
SILICON VALLEY COMPETITIVENESS
AND INNOVATION PROJECT THAT
LOOKS AT THE EFFECTS OF HOUSING
CRISIS THE HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR
REGION.
THE REPORT FOUND THAT BETWEEN
TWO THOUSAND TEN IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE SILICON
VALLEY HAD A NEW JOB GROWTH AT
29%.
WHILE ONLY HAVING NEW HOUSING
GROWTH OF 4%.
COLLECTIVELY LEADERSHIP GROUP
MEMBERS PROVIDE NEARLY ONE OUT
OF EVERY THREE PRIVATE SECTOR
JOBS IN THE SILICON VALLEY.
AND EVERY CONVERSATION WE'VE HAD
WITH OUR SOUL SEC IF WE HEAR
ABOUT RECRUITMENT AND RETENTION
AS THE NUMBER ONE THREAT TO OUR
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
OUR COMPANIES ARE STRUGGLING TO
ATTRACT AND KEEP EMPLOYEES AT
ALL LEVELS BECAUSE OF THE COST
OF HOUSING.
SB EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT IS IN LINE
WITH LONGTIME LAND USE
PRINCIPLES OF THE LEADERSHIP
GROUP TO INCREASE HOUSING SUPPLY
AND ENSURE THAT OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ARE DOING THEIR
NECESSARY FAIR SHARE.
OF BUILDING NEW HOUSING SB EIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT IS THE FIRST STEP
IN GETTING TO MORE EFFECTIVE
RINA PROCESS AND IT'S CRITICAL
TO ADDRESS OUR STATE'S WORSENING
HOUSING CRISIS.
WE THANK YOU AND WE ARE TRITE
BUT CHURCHILL AND MEMBERS
MICHAEL AND WITH THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE RINA
REFORM AND MODERNIZATION THAT S.
B. I. TWENTY EIGHT REPRESENTS.
THE SCARCITY OF PROPERTIES OWNED
MULTI FAMILY SITES OUR
COMPETITIVE PER STATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FINANCE PROGRAM IS A
REAL PROBLEM.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY EIGHT
ADDRESSES BY REQUIRING THE
JURISDICTIONS OWN FOR MORE SUCH
SITES.
THIS REPORTEDLY SOME DOWNWARD
PRESSURE ON SKYROCKETING LAMB
PRICES AND ENSURE SUFFICIENT
PARCELS ARE AVAILABLE.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT%
THE BAY AREA WERE LACKING GO FOR
TEN MILLION DOLLARS PER ACRE
MORE MORE.
THERE ARE THREE INGREDIENTS
NEEDED TO DEVELOP AFFORDABLE
HOUSING LAND TO FUNDING AND
POLITICAL WILL TO GET PROJECTS
APPROVED.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THE ISSUE OF
LAND IN ITS AVAILABILITY AND
VIABILITY FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT.
THE METHODOLOGY CALLED FOR AN
SBA TWENTY EIGHT TO ASSESS AND
ALLOCATE THE TRUE HOUSING NEED
WILL PROVIDE BOTH GREATER
ACCURACY.
AND EQUITY IN THOSE RINA NUMBERS
AND FAIR SHARE [inaudible]
DISTRIBUTION.
CREATING A BUFFER BY SELLING FOR
MORE THAN JUST 1100% OF THE
ALLOCATION IS IT IS A BEST
PRACTICE THAT SOME JURISDICTIONS
ALREADY USE BUT MORE NEED TO DO
THIS IN THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE
THAT WE THINK THAT'S THAT'S
IMPORTANT.
AND FOR THESE REASONS REAP
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE GOT OTHER
SUPPORT IS A LIKE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY.
CHIU HERE CHIU HERE MAIENSCHEIN.
CHAO.
CHOI HERE SHOW HERE GLORIA GLORY
HERE ONLY MONTH.
AND AMONG HERE WOULD WOULD BE
HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM WITH THAT
LET'S GO TO OTHER SUPPORTERS
NAME AND TITLE PLACE THANK YOU.
JENNIFER SPENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT.
THINGS CHAIR KEEFE THEN ON
BEHALF CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SYLVIA OFFERING TO
HAVE A FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT.
KEVIN ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
MORNING ASSISTANCE AND I'M HALF
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SPORT.
MONETARY MEMBERS THIS FRONT AND
BE HAPPY CALIFORNIA VIA
TRANSPORT.
AND A MUSICIAN WITH THE LEAGUE
OF WOMEN VOTERS A CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
CORNELIUS BROKE THE BEAR COUNCIL
SUPPORT.
TIFFANY FAN OF HOW THE BRIDGE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT.
PLAY SHEPHERD AGAIN FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT.
AND LET ME NOW ASK IF THERE ARE
ANY.
FOLKS IN OPPOSITION.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AND I DO WANT TO
POINT OUT FIRST THAT THERE ARE
ACTUALLY SEVERAL PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL THAT WE SUPPORT AND
SEE TAX SUPPORTS.
LOOKING AT THE RENO PROCESS AND
PUTTING SOME GUARDRAILS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE ALLOCATING THE
HOUSING PLANNING AND
REQUIREMENTS TO THOSE
JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE JOBS AND
TRANSIT AND OVERCROWDING AND
UNMET DEMAND.
AND SO WE THINK THE SECTIONS OF
THIS BILL FOR FIVE OR SORRY FIVE
AND SIX BETTER RELATED TO THAT
PROCESS AND IMPROVING NOT
PROCESS ARE LEGITIMATE AND WE
WOULD BE HAPPY TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION IF THAT WERE ALL THAT
THE BILL THAT.
THE PARTS OF THE BILL THAT WE
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT HOWEVER
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
THE RINA ALLOCATION OR
ASSESSMENT PROCESS BUT RATHER
WITH THE HOUSING ELEMENT PROCESS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
SO FOR INSTANCE SECTION ONE A
REQUIREMENT THAT IF YOU CAN'T
HIT ALL OF YOUR ADEQUATE SITES
IN TERMS OF LAND THAT'S ALREADY
ZONED FOR HOUSING.
IT PUTS FURTHER RESTRICTIONS
BEYOND WHAT'S ALREADY INCLUDED
IN THE HOUSING ELEMENT LAW ON
WHERE THAT LEE AND THAT CAN BE
DEDICATED FOR HOUSING HOUSE TO
BE LOCATED.
SO CURRENTLY THE DEFINITION
THAT'S INCLUDED IN THE BILL IS
LITERALLY UNWORKABLE FOR
COUNTIES AND WHILE WE'VE BEEN
TALKING TO THE AUTHORS OFFICE
ABOUT POTENTIALLY INCLUDING
OTHER.
AND LIMITATIONS ARE PEOPLE ARE
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT NOT BEING
ABLE TO MEET THE ADEQUATE SITES
UNDER THE THRESHOLDS FROM
THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN LAST YEAR.
AND THEN BEING PUT IN A BOX IN
TERMS OF ALSO NOT HAVING ENOUGH
SITES FOR WHERE THEY CAN REZONE
IT ALSO MEET THESE NEW
REQUIREMENTS.
I AM FOR SECTION TWO AND THREE
WHICH IS THE REQUIREMENT TO ZONE
FOR A 125% OF YOUR ADEQUATE
SITES AND WE'RE VERY CONCERNED
WITH THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN AND
ONE SIXTY SIX LAST YEAR.
WHICH BOTH ATTEMPTED TO ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM AND WHICH REALLY
HAVEN'T BEEN IMPLEMENTED YET
BECAUSE FOLKS HAVEN'T DONE THEIR
FIRST HOUSING ELEMENTS UNDER
THOSE NEW STANDARDS.
SO THIRTEEN NINETY SEVEN INSURES
THAT THE SITES THAT ARE INCLUDED
IN THE INVENTORY ARE THE MOST
EASILY DEVELOP ALL POLL SITES
AND SO THEY'RE GOOD SITES AN SP
ONE SIXTY SIX REQUIRES THAT
THERE ALWAYS BE AN ADEQUATE
SUPPLY OF SITES. TO MEET YOUR
REMAINING THAT RINA ALLOCATION
SO WE DID A NEW THRESHOLD THAT
SAYS THE SITE HAVE TO BE EASY TO
DEVELOP AND WE ALWAYS HAVE TO
HAVE ENOUGH SITE SO WE THINK
WE'VE ALREADY FIX THIS PROBLEM.
AS RELATED TO RUNNING OUT OF
ADEQUATE SITES DURING THE
PLANNING PERIOD WITH LAST YEAR'S
LEGISLATION AND WE DON'T THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE TO ADD A NEW
THRESHOLD AND AND REQUIRE --
THAT HUNDRED AND 25% A LEVEL
FINALLY WITH AND SECTION FOUR OF
THE BILL WE ARE A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS LANGUAGE
IT'S KIND OF LIKE STATUTORY
INTENT LANGUAGE.
BUT IT DESCRIBES WHAT RINA
REALLY IS AND SO WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED WITH STRIKING THE
LANGUAGE THAT REALLY DOES
RECOGNIZE THAT DESPITE ALL THE
BEST EFFORTS OF CITIES AND
COUNTIES SOMETIMES DEVELOPMENT
BECAUSE OF THE MARKET BECAUSE OF
WHATEVER.
DOESN'T MEET THOSE THRESHOLDS
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO REVISE
THAT LANGUAGE TO AT LEAST.
MAINTAINED SOME RECOGNITION OF
THE FACT THAT THERE'S PARTS OF
THE MARKET THAT ARE JUST BEYOND
GOVERNMENT CONTROL AND SO WITH
THOSE AMENDMENTS WILL BE ABLE TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION BUT FOR
NOW WE ARE OPPOSE LET'S AMENDED
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING BILL HIGGINS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENTS WE HAVE
BEEN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION BUT WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN TAKE AND RIGHT NOW IN
TERMS OF THAT THE STATEWIDE
FACTORS.
WERE THE THING THAT WE'RE DOING
RIGHT NOW IS WE'RE CHECKING TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT WORKS WITH OUR
SMALLER COGS BECAUSE IT WAS
PROBABLY INFLUENCE WITH YOUR
WORK WITH ONE OF OUR LARGER
MEMBERS.
AND SO WE'RE JUST MAKING SURE
THAT IT WORKS ACROSS THE BOARD.
BUT THE SECOND THING AND I IS
THAT WE HAVE THIS COMMITTEE
PISSED UP PASSED OUT A BILL AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY ONE BLOOM.
THAT DEALS WITH SOME OF THE SAME
ISSUES.
AND WE CAN'T REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION UNTIL THOSE TWO ARE
IN SYNC BECAUSE THAT RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE APPROACHING THE SAME
PROBLEM AND DIFFERENT WAYS AND
WE ENCOURAGE EVERYBODY TO GET IN
THE SAME ROOM AND TALK ABOUT
THAT.
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE TO BILLS
AT THE END OF THE THE THING THEN
THE LAST ISSUE.
IS AN ISSUE THAT I THINK WE DO
NEED TO WORK ON ALL TOGETHER.
BECAUSE THIS IS ASKING OUR
MEMBERS TO DISTRIBUTE HOUSING
UNITS ON A FAIR SHARE PRINCIPLE.
AND THAT WILL RESULT IN A VERY
DIFFERENT DISTRIBUTION VAN WHAT
YOU ANOTHER LAWS YOU WE HAVE ITS
S. B. THREE SEVENTY FIVE THAT
SAYS WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT.
A DISTRIBUTION THAT REDUCES GHG
[inaudible] TO HIT.
S. B. THREE SEVENTY FIVE TARGETS.
AND WE DON'T WANT TO BE IN A
SITUATION THAT IF THIS BILL
PASSED RIGHT NOW.
WE WOULD BE IN A SITUATION WHERE
WE HAVE A ARE BE PUSHING US ON
ONE LEVEL. TO GET ONE RESULT AND
H. CD DOING A DIFFERENT WE NEED
THE STATE TO WORK TOGETHER ON
THOSE TWO ISSUES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM IT'S GREAT
TO WORK WITH US ON THAT YOU'VE
NODDED YOUR HEAD YES AT LEAST
LAST TIME I TOUCHED BY THIS I'M
HOPING WE CAN WORK THAT ISSUE
OUT BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT WE NEED
TO DO IN ORDER. TO MAKE SURE THE
STATE SPEAKING WITH ONE VOICE.
THE MASS FOR OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
IN OPPOSITION MR OF MR MEMBERS
USE RIGHTLY CALIFORNIA CITIES
AND WE HAVEN'T WAS LESS SIMILAR
POSITIONS WELL WE SHARE MANY OF
THE THE COMMENTS THAT I SEE SEC
MATE.
WE APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK WITH
US WITH GOING BACK AND FORTH AS
A STAFF WERE HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN
GET THERE --
BUT FOR NOW WE HAVEN'T
BUSINESSMAN POSITION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN EVER DAVID JONES
BEHALF OF SAN MARCOS IN THE
CITIES IN MARIN COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR ALICE KESSLER HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH AND RESPECTFULLY WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
KELLY BUCKS ON BEHALF OF THE
ROLE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
AND OF THE SAME CONCERNS AS HE'S
ACTING CAM.
ANY OTHER ORGANIZATIONS LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ALAMY ELSA CENTER IF YOU WANNA
RESPOND TO YOUR OPPOSITION
PROPER THROW WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING --
HARD WITH LITTLE WITH THE LEAGUE
WITH C. SAP WITH CAL BECAUSE WE
MADE.
AMENDMENTS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK OUT WITH THAT DEFINITION OF
INFILL OR ANY OF THESE OTHER
ISSUES ARE --
AND AND BY IN TERMS OF THE
INTENT LANGUAGE THAT'S YOU SUCK
ON MENTIONED WERE ALREADY
WORKING I BELIEVE WITH THE
LEAGUE ON THAT SO.
OR MAYBE WITH CALCOT ACCOUNT
NUMBER BUT I'M GONNA CONTINUE TO
WORK OF WITH ALL OF THEM --
I'M WE WILL DEFINITELY BRING
COMMUNICATION WITH THE SPONSORS
OF THE BLOOM READ A BILL WE
OBVIOUSLY WANT THEM TO BE
COMPLEMENTARY AND FOR ALL I
THINK ALL.
ARE COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE.
I THOUGHT THAT THAT HAPPENS --
BUT I I THINK IT'S A GOOD BILL
AN IMPORTANT STOP AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND DAD JUST FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE APPRECIATE YOUR
ADVOCACY OVER --
HOUSING AND I THINK WE ALL AGREE
THAT THAT RENA IT HAS BEEN IN
NEED OF REFORM IT HAS NOT
ACCOMPLISH WHAT WE NEEDED TO DO.
I APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS THAT OUR
COMMITTEE HAS RECOMMENDED --
AND SUPPORT THESE EFFORTS TO
PUSH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO UP
BILL MORE HOUSING SO WITH THAT I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY LET ME ASK IF THERE OTHER
COMMENTS.
MISTER GLORIA DAVID CHAIRMAN AND
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL
I'M I'M CERTAINLY SUPPORTIVE OF
IT I DIDN'T WANT YOU TO MAYBE
EXPAND IT MORE ON THE
OPPOSITION'S COMMENTS ABOUT THE
THE THE PUSH AND PULL BETWEEN
CAR.
AND THE LITTLE BIT THEY SHOULD
WE JUST MENTIONED CAN YOU SPEAK
MORE ABOUT WHAT YOU THINK.
IT WILL HAPPEN TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT ENCOURAGING SPRAWL
THAT AND WE THIS IS OUR I THINK
A IN HER INTENTION AND HOUSING
POLICY IN.
CALIFORNIA PA AND EVERYONE'S
RIGHT TO DIE WELL ON THE ONE
HAND [inaudible]
WE WANT.
SUSTAINABLE DEVELOPMENT WHERE
WE'RE CONCENTRATING HOUSING.
YOU KNOW AROUND TRANSIT AROUND
IN JOB CENTERS --
NOT CREATING SPRAWL ON THE OTHER
HAND I WE WANT EQUITY SO WE
DON'T HAVE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
OPTING OUT OF HOUSING THAT ARE
SAYING NO LOW INCOME HOUSING
HERE -- AND
SO FORTH AND WE HAVE TO BALANCE
THE TWO WE ARE --
WE HAVE WE HAVE AMENDED THIS IN
THE TO TO TRY TO REDRESS BY --
TALK ABOUT CONCENTRATING
DEVELOPMENT IN THESE MORE
SUSTAINABLE AREAS LIKE AROUND
WHICH HAS TO SHOULD BE DIFFICULT
LANGUAGE AND TO THAT EFFECT.
I AND YOU KNOW THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT -- IT
IS IMPORTANT BUT ISN'T
EXCEPTIONALLY HARD BALANCE TO
STRIKE AND LIKE I SAID ACT ON
BOTH SIDES OF THAT ARGUMENT
EVERYONE'S RIGHT --
AND SO WHAT WILL CONTINUE TO TRY
TO STRIKE A BALANCE WELL
APPRECIATED PERSISTENCE IN THE
IT ATTEMPTS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY FUNDAMENTALLY GET
MORE HOUSING BUILT WHICH IS
ULTIMATELY I THINK THIS BILL IS
TO DELIVER ENDEAVORING TO DO --
ENDS YOU KNOW IT IS WHO RENTS
ARE TOO HIGH HOUSING IS TO ON
AFFORDABLE I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
DON'T VOTE FOR AN EFFORT THAT
TRIES TO MOVE THIS FORWARD SO I
APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING FORWARD
IT IS DIFFICULT.
AND YOU MAY KNOW MY OWN COUNTY
WE CAN STRUGGLING WITH THE
DESIRED OF LOWER --
THEIR MEAN A STANDARD THINK
WE'VE SUCCESS COULD NOT THAT
THAT -- THIS
BILL I THINK ONLY A STICKS IN
THE FURTHER IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION SO WE APPRECIATE THE
PERSISTENCE OF HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL.
IT'S BEEN A MOTION OF THE BILLS
ARE SECOND THEIR SECOND THAT ANY
FURTHER COMMENTS CENTER ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS RESPECT WITH
LENOVO.
WITH THAT OF MADAM SECRETARY.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE COMMITTEE
ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
CHIU AYE CHIU AYE MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
CHAO.
CHAU AYE.
CHOI [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE LIMA [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
WAIT I YOU EFFORT VOTES YOUR
BILL IT WILL BE OUT BUT WILL
WAIT FOR ADDITIONAL ANALYST YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
MEGACENTRE [inaudible]
CENTER BATES.
WILL BE.
CONSIDERING FILE ITEM THREE SB
[inaudible]
TWELVE TWENTY SIX SENATOR
WELCOME.
WELL GOOD MORNING ON MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AYE AYE AGAIN
WE HAVE --
BEFORE YOU A BILL THAT SEEKS TO
ADDRESS FIVE THEY HOUSING ISSUES.
ARE S. B. R. TWELVE TWENTY SIX
DIRECTS THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
STANDARDS COMMISSION TO ADOPTED
BUILDING STANDARD.
THAT WOULD CLARIFY THE AUTHORITY
FOR A LOCAL BUILDING OFFICIAL TO
PERMIT AN EXISTING RESIDENTIAL
UNIT.
LEASE ON THE DATE OF
CONSTRUCTION CURRENT STATUTE
DELEGATES LOCAL BUILDING
OFFICIALS WITH THE AUTHORITY TO
APPLY THE CURRENT PROVISIONS OF
THE BUILDING STANDARDS CODE.
BUT CURRENT LAW IS UNCLEAR ABOUT
A LOCAL BUILDING OFFICIALS
ABILITY TO GO BACK IN THE CODE
TO PERMIT THESE RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES.
THE BILL SEEKS TO MAKE IT CLEAR
AND TO CLARIFY EXISTING PRACTICE
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES NEED TO
FIND OUT WHERE THESE ON
PERMITTED EXISTING RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES ARE.
BRING THEM UP TO A SUITABLE
LEVEL IN THE CODE WHICH ENSURES
BASIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
STANDARDS.
THE BILL WAS APPROVED ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS AS IT I WENT
THROUGH THE SENATE AND RECEIVED
NO NO VOTES IN COMMITTEE I HAVE
A TO HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT TODAY MAYOR CATHERINE
BLACKS FEAR.
AND JONATHAN I'M MAYOR CATHERINE
LAXER OF ANTHONY DESK IN MY
DISTRICT AND JONATHAN CLAY WHO'S
HERE TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS BOTH ARE WITH THE CITY
OF ENCINITAS.
CATHERINE FOR GOVERNING GOOD
MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY I'M CATHOLIC SPARE THE
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF ENCINITAS
AND I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE AS
THE SPONSORING CITY FOR SP
TWELVE TWENTY SIX AUTHORED BY
OUR STATE SENATOR PAT BATES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OTHER CURRENTLY WE ESTIMATE THAT
IN THE CITY OF ENCINITAS THERE
ARE AT LEAST A THOUSAND
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS THAT
ARE ON PERMITTED.
BUT ARE A VITAL PART OF OUR
EXISTING HOUSING STOCK AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE MANY
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE ALSO IN
THIS POSITION.
MANY OF THE OWNERS OF THESE
UNITS LIVE IN THE SHADOWS AND
THEY FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE THAT
THEIR NEIGHBOR COULD TURN THE
MEN WITH ONE PHONE CALL.
BUT THEY'RE ALSO UNABLE TO
PERMIT THE UNIT BASED ON IN
FEASIBILITY OR PROHIBITIVELY
HIGH COST.
AND SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES S. B.
TOLD TWENTY SIX IS THAT
CLARIFIES THAT A LOCAL BUILDING
OFFICIAL HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
PERMIT THESE ALREADY OCCUPIED
HOMES.
BASED ON THE BUILDING STANDARD
THAT WAS IN A FACT WHEN THE UNIT
WAS CONSTRUCTED.
I'VE HEARD FROM RESIDENTS THAT
THEY'RE VERY OLD ACCESSORY UNITS
SOME OF THEM ARE MORE THAN
THIRTY YEARS OLD PRE DATING OUR
CITIES AND CORPORATION.
ARE NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO PERMIT
UNDER OUR CURRENT CODES.
AND SO THEIR ONLY OPTION WOULD
BE REMOVAL OF THIS YEAR THESE
UNITS WHICH IS NOT IDEAL FOR
THEM AS THE LANDOWNER OR FOR THE
CITY AND THE STATE AND A HOUSING
CRISIS.
SO AS A GOVERNMENT WORK
CONCERNED ABOUT MAINTAINING IN
CREATING A SAFE HOUSING STOCK.
AND WERE ALSO TRYING TO DO
WHATEVER WE CAN TO PROVIDE MORE
HOUSING IN OUR CITY NOT LESS.
SO THIS BILL WILL LEAD TO MORE
PERMITTED HOMES AND THEREFORE AN
INCREASE IN SAFE HOMES AND WE
APPRECIATE SENATOR BATES
AUTHORING THIS BILL FOR US AND
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING --
I ME KATIE ALMOND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING OFFICIALS TODAY.
AND I WANT TO SPEAK AS TO THE
LOCAL ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS THAT
ACTUALLY HELP DEVELOP THESE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODES AND
ENFORCE THEM ON A DAILY BASIS.
BUILDING OFFICIALS CURRENTLY
HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO PERMIT
STRUCTURES ARE ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS AND THEREFORE PLACING THIS
DUPLICATIVE LANGUAGE IN STATUTE --
WOULD ONLY A INTERFERE WITH THE
CONSISTENCY OF REGULATORY CODE.
AS PART OF CALVET SIX POINT
POLICY A WE DO NOT SUPPORT COULD
IMPLEMENTATION THROUGH THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS RATHER THE
REGULATORY PROCESS FOR THE
CONSISTENCY AND ACCURACY.
BY THIS PART OF THE AUTHORITY --
TO PERMIT THE STRUCTURES ALREADY
IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN IBC I RC
IN THE EPC BUILDING CODES.
CALVO SUPPORTS IMPLEMENTATION OF
LOCAL ORDINANCES WHICH ALLOW FOR
THE AT ADAPTATION AND ACCOUNT
FOR THE DIVERSE REGIONS OF OUR
STATE.
COUPLE WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE TRAINING ASPECT AND NOT
LEGISLATIVE CODE IMPLEMENTATION.
PLACING THIS ENFORCEMENT IN
STATUTE DOES NOT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT.
AGAIN THE CITIES AND THE
POPULATIONS THAT THESE EIGHTY
USE RESIDE IN CALPERS SUPPORTS
LOCALITIES A DEVELOPING THESE
ORDINANCES AND WHEN IT TURNED
OUT SUPPORT THESE LOCAL NEEDS
THANK YOU.
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S ANY.
OTHER INDIVIDUALS WILL LIKE TO
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
OKAY BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS.
MISTER GORE.
ITEMS SHARE AND THAT NEAR IT'S
GREAT TO SEE YOU OUTLOOK SENIOR
UP -- I'VE
CERTAINLY HEARD THIS FROM
CONSTITUENTS IN MY MIND AND THAT.
I WOULD LIKE TO COME INTO
COMPLIANCE BUT WE ARE STUCK WITH
THAT I HEARD THE COMMENTS OF THE
OPPOSITION I THINK ONE AND MAYBE
THIS IS FOR A FOR YOU --
I THINK A PART OF THIS BILL IS
CLEAR FINE WHEN BECAUSE THEY
HAVE.
TO BRING IT UP TO RIGHT I THINK
MOST THAT MAY LEAST MY SPIRITS
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT THEY'D THE
EXISTING RADIO OWNER WOULD HAVE
TO BRING IT UP CURRENT CODE.
AS OPPOSED TO NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINETEEN EIGHTY WHATEVER BECAUSE
GOD NO PLEASE UM THEY CAN
ACTUALLY PERMIT ON A P. CASE BY
CASE BASIS CURRENTLY AND APPLY
WHAT THEY FEEL IN THEIR OPINION
IN THEIR AUTHORITY APPLIES TO
THE EIGHTY OR SO.
AS LONG AS SAFETY AND HEALTH
MEASURES ARE MET THEY CAN GO
BACKWARDS AS LONG AS THEY THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE TIME.
IT'S VERY SUBJECTIVE ALRIGHT.
AGAIN IT'S THEIR AUTHORITIES
YEAH SO IT'S IN THEIR EXPERTISE
MA'AM SYMPATHETIC TO WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING IN TERMS OF WHAT WE PUT
INTO THE TO THE CODE OF WHAT WE
DON'T HARM BUT THE SAME TIME.
YOU KNOW I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WE HAVE WITH ALL
RESPECT TO OUR LOCALS YOU KNOW
IS REALLY MAKING SURE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE DOING WHAT
THEY CAN TO BRING.
UP TO ACTUALLY FACILITATE AND
THIS IS A EIGHTIES ARE NOT A
PANACEA AND THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO SOLVE OUR HOUSING CRISIS
HOWEVER --
THESE ARE UNITS FOR WHICH PEOPLE
SHOULD HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
AS THEY WERE SAYING --
HAVING THEM ATTENDED TO CODE
COMPLIANCE VETERAN BASICALLY
FINANCIALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO BRING
TO CODE AND THEN THE UNIT JUST
COMES OFF THE THE INVENTORY
THINK THAT'S WHAT.
THE THE AUTHOR THAT CITY BATES
TRYING TO DEAL WITH CRAP --
SO I'D THAT SUBJECTIVITY I THINK
YOU MAY HAVE SOME JURISDICTIONS
WITH A BILL IN OFFICIALS WILL
PROBABLY.
APPROACH WITH MORE CAN DO
CUSTOMER SERVICE ATTITUDE IN
RIGHT I'M DEPEND ON THEIR THEIR
VIEW ON EIGHTY IS AYE I THINK
THAT'S THE VALUE OF THIS BILL --
AND SILLY NOT THE LEAST OF WHICH
IS TO MAKE SURE SOME OF ITS
HOUSING IS BROUGHT UP FROM
WHATEVER CURRENT STANDARDS THAT
MAY BE.
HOMEOWNER MAY WANNA MAKE AN
IMPROVEMENT BUT THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO HELP CONVERT PERMITS
FOR IT IF IT'S ON PERMITTED IN
THE FIRST PLACE CRACK RIGHT.
SO THAT WE TO THE ONE QUESTION I
HAD A ONE MAYBE OF AS AS LOOKING
AT THE BILL --
CONCERN IS THEORETICALLY IF
THERE ARE IMPROVEMENTS THAT CAN
BE MADE THAT MAY REQUIRE
RELOCATION.
OF THE EXISTING TENET AND THE
BILL DOESN'T REALLY SPEAK TO
WHAT HAPPENS THAT TENET IF AND
WHEN THAT HAPPENS I REALIZE THAT
THAN THAT ADJUSTMENTS COULD BE
FAIRLY MINOR THAT COULD BE
FAIRLY MAJOR --
IF IF GIVING A A PROPERTY OWNER
WHO THEORETICALLY MAYBE DIDN'T
QUITE FOLLOW RULES OF WHEN THIS
WAS CREATED --
I'M I'M A LITTLE HESITANT ABOUT
PUTTING THAT BURDEN ON THE ON A
TENANT WHO.
MAYBE IF THE FED COMFORTABLE
LIFE -- BUT
MAY SUDDENLY BE DISRUPTED
BECAUSE WE GRANTED THIS
AUTHORITY CAN YOU SPEAK.
TO I SENATORS FOR YOU AS THE
AUTHOR --
WHAT YOUR VIEW IS ON ON WHAT
SHOULD HAPPEN TO THE TENANTS
THAT ARE IN THESE UNITS THAT'S
INTERESTING YOU BRING THAT
FORWARD TO THE SONY MEN ARE
GLORIA BECAUSE?
SEVERAL YEARS AGO WHEN WE
INCORPORATED IN SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY THE CITY OF LAGUNA BEACH
SOUTH WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A LOT
OF THESE PARTICULAR ISSUES.
WHAT WAS MOST IMPORTANT IDEAS
SAW CERTAINLY WITH THIS
PARTICULAR BILL THE FIRE SAFETY
STANDARDS ARE THE ONES THAT HAVE
TO BE ENFORCED WHATEVER?
YOU KNOW I WE HAVE BEEN IN AN
INDIVIDUAL YOU THOSE UNITS AT
THAT TIME THERE WAS A RELOCATION
PROBLEMS.
FOUND THE CITY ACTUALLY TOOK
THAT ON AND I THINK THAT THAT
WOULD BE CERTAINLY SOMETHING --
THAT WOULD LIVE WOULD BE LOOKED
AT IN A DISCRETIONARY FASHION
BUT OTHER THAN THAT I NEED TO
GET ON SO THE CITY RELOCATED
YEAH WELL THEY HAD THE DID HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR OF VOUCHERS --
FOR YOU KNOW HOTELS Y. AT THAT
TIME AND WE'RE TALKING. TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AGO I THINK THIRTY
YEARS AGO --
WHEN ALL THAT HAPPENED AND IT
WAS SPREE MOB PRETTY MAJOR AT
THAT TIME?
THAT I THINK THAT SOMETHING THAT
THE CITY WOULD HAVE TO LOOK AT
IN TERMS OF HOW MANY AND YOU
KNOW WHAT THE PROBLEM WOULD BE
AN ESPECIALLY WITH SENIORS.
THAT CAN BE A REAL ISSUE BUT
CHAO SOMETHING THAT I THINK GOES
BACK TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
DISCRETION AND CERTAINLY THE WAY
THEY LOOK AT TAKING CARE OF
THEIR THEIR RESIDENTS.
WHO MIGHT FIND THEMSELVES IN
THAT DIFFICULT POSITION?
WHY WOULD YOU SAY HE THERE'S
THERE'S VALUE CAN CONVEY TO THE
PROPERTY ON RIGHT BY THE OUT OF
BRING SOMETHING INTO COMPLIANCE
MAKE IT LEGAL IMPROVE THEIR
PROPERTY VALUE THEY --
IT'S ALL UPSIDE FOR THE FOR THE
PROPERTY OWNER.
I'M OFTEN CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TENANT INVOLVED IN I'D YOU KNOW
I'M I REALIZE IT'S NOT A
QUESTION OF MISSILE BEFORE US
TODAY AND CERTAINLY YOUR BILL TO
DO WITH WHAT YOU AS YOU SEE FIT
PASS MAYBE GONNA GO FOR BASIS TO
GIVE SOME CONSIDERATION. TO WHAT
OUGHT TO BE DONE FOR THE TENANTS.
WHO THEORETICALLY WILL GET NO
UPSIDE TYPICALLY IF HAVE TO BE
RELOCATED AND?
I'M ANYONE IS OUT ON THAT ON THE
MIDDLE MARKET RIGHT NOW COULD I
AND IN YOUR QUESTION A LITTLE OR
SO.
I THINK THE THE MAIN BENEFIT IS
THAT FOR THE TENANTS THAT
THEY'RE LIVING IN A PLACE THAT'S
ACTUALLY SAFE.
SO THERE IS A CONCERN THAT
PEOPLE ARE LIVING IN PLACES THAT
ARE NOT SAFE AND THEY'RE NOT UP
TO FIRE STANDARDS OR OR OTHER
STANDARDS.
AND AT LEAST FROM MY EXPERIENCE
OF THE PEOPLE WHO COME IN AND
MEET WITH ME ABOUT THEIR
CONCERNS.
THEY'D THEY WOULDN'T BE
PROACTIVELY KICKING SOMEBODY OUT
TO MAKE THESE IMPROVEMENTS WHAT
THEY WOULD BE DOING AT THE TIME
WHEN IT WOULD NATURALLY TURN
OVER WHETHER SOME OTHER TYPE OF
REASON THAT THE TENANT MOVES OUT
ON THEIR OWN.
OR IT INVOLVES A FAMILY MEMBER
MULTI GENERATIONAL AND SO IT'S A
WAY TO TO TO HELP THAT PROCESS
MOVE ALONG AND PROVIDE CLARITY
TO THE BUILDING OFFICIAL.
BUT ITS I I DON'T SEE THERE AS
BEING I'M OF A MAD RUSH TO KICK
OUT PEOPLE GET THESE PERMITS
COULD I JUST SEE IT AS ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THEM BE
PERMITTED BUT I I WOULD BE
SURPRISED IF WE ACTUALLY SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM.
BUT I I AGREE WITH YOU IT'S A
CONCERN --
BUT BUT I I DO I DO THINK THAT
IT'S IT'S THE HIGHEST GOOD IS
THE SAFETY OF RESIDENTS IN ALL
OF OUR COMMUNITIES AGREE --
WHAT DE I'VE AND I APPRECIATE
THAT INPUT ON THAT --
THIS CHAIR I BELIEVE THIS ENJOYS
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION I'M I'M
LIVE THAT'S WITH THE RATE THIS
MOTION MOVE IT AND A SECOND ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION.
BUT MR GLORIA THINK CAPTURED MY
OWN PERSPECTIVE ON THIS WHICH IS
WHILE.
NOT THESE RULES ARE IN THE CODE --
THERE CLEARLY ARE SOME A LACK OF
CLARITY ARE AS I THINK WE'VE ALL
DISCOVERED AND I ALSO DO NOT SEE
THE HARM IN IN PUTTING THIS --
INTO STATUTES OF THAT THERE'S
SPORTS SO --
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL DOES NOT
RECEIVE MY SUPPORT AND WITH THAT
ANY FINAL COMMENTS FROM THE
CENTER RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I BILLION APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION.
THINK THAT WAS A VERY IMPORTANT
POINT THAT YOU BROUGHT UP WHEN
WE SEE WE HAVE THE RENTAL CRISIS
GOING ON AT THE SAME TIME THAT.
THINK A WITH A HUMANITARIAN
APPROACH THAT WE NOW HAVE IN OUR
CITIES WITH REGARD SOME HOMELESS
FOR ALL THAT.
I THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE
SOMETHING CITIES WOULD TAKE
UNDER SERIOUS CONSIDERATION THAT
YOU WOULD WANT TO DISPLAY SOME
MONEY AND LET'S SAY BANANA UNIT
FOR TWENTY YEARS AND YOU KNOW --
ACTUALLY RENTING OR PERHAPS EVEN
WHERE THEY HAVE A A RELATIVE SO
I THINK THAT CAN BE SOLVED ARE
VERY.
EASILY MAYBE NOT QUICKLY BUT
EASILY I ASK THE COUNCIL'S LOOK
AT INDIVIDUAL CASES.
WELL THANK YOU GREAT AND WITHOUT
OF MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS CHIU BY CHIU AYE
MAIENSCHEIN CHAO.
SHALL I CHOI.
GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE LAMONT THE
MONTH I WOULD.
WOULD I YOUR BILLS UP.
THANK YOU ANDA.
WE'RE CALLING THE FINAL AUTHORS --
CENTERS WIEKOWSKI AND MCGUIRE
AND HOPEFULLY ONE OF THEM WILL
COME SHORTLY
[inaudible]
MY COUNTY
THERE'S A IT SHOULDN'T BE A
PROBLEM
[inaudible]
OKAY HAD [inaudible]
NOT
[inaudible]
WE'RE YEAH IT WAS A PROBLEM
OKAY [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
OVERVIEW
[inaudible]
AND TO NOW YOU'RE PROBABLY ABOUT
PASSED.
I KNOW YEARS AND YEARS
[inaudible]
IF YOU [inaudible]
YOU [inaudible]
EVEN IF
.
WHEN THEY GOT CHOI [inaudible]
BUT MY EXOTIC [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
OTHER
BACK
[inaudible]
YEAH HEAV'N.
WE HAD ALMOST A FULL COMPLEMENT
BUT OF APOLOGIES THAT WE DON'T
BUT IN THE MEANTIME WE CAN STILL
PROCEED CENTER MCGUIRE WELCOME
S. B.. ELEVEN A STORY.
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN FILE ITEM FIVE
A MISTER CHAIR IN GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING CHEERED FANTASTIC
STAFF VERY GRATEFUL UP FOR ALL
OF YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL THIS
WAS A VERY CAPABLE TEAM.
LATE ON THE NIGHT OF DECEMBER
SECOND TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN A
CATASTROPHIC FIRE --
PARA CONVERTED WAREHOUSE KNOWN
AS THE GHOST SHIP RESULTED IN
THE TRAGIC DEATHS. THIRTY SIX
RESIDENTS THE HIGHEST DEATH TOLL
FOR STRUCTURAL FIRE IN THE
UNITED STATES INDICATES.
I IT WAS TRULY DEVASTATING THAT
FOR THE CITY BROKEN THE REST OF
THE STATE.
IN RESPONSE TO THIS FIRE THE
SENATE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE HELL TO LEGISLATIVE
HEARINGS IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
HOME DISTRICT SENATOR SENATOR
SKINNER.
AND CONVENE A WORKING GROUP TO
IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS TO ENSURE
THAT NOTHING LIKE TO STRATEGY
WOULD HAPPEN AGAIN HERE IN THE
CITY CALIFORNIA.
BUILDING OFFICIALS PROPERTY
OWNERS.
BUT CAL FIRE CHIEFS ARE ALL WERE
AROUND THE TABLE.
S. B. FOURTEEN FIFTEEN IN THE
SECOND OF TWO BILLS THAT MAKE
SUGGESTIONS FROM A ROBUST
WORKING GROUP WHOSE MEMBERS MET
FOR MONTHS.
APARTAMENTO LA.
WE'VE WORKED HARD TO WALK THE
LINE TO ENSURE SAFETY WHILE
KEEPING TENANTS HOUSE.
WHILE HOUSING PRICES.
SUCH AS THEY ARE IN I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR WHO'S
BEEN CHAMPING FOR THAT.
PEOPLE ARE SOMETIMES FORCED TO
LIVE IN BUILDINGS THAT WERE
NEVER MEANT TO HOUSE PEOPLE.
AND THAT'S WHY THIS BILL EXTENDS
RELOCATION BENEFITS TO TENANTS
OF I'M PERMITTED SPACES WHEN
THEY'RE FORCED TO VACATE DUE TO
UNSAFE CONDITIONS.
THIS BILL ALSO IMPROVES THE
PROCESS FOR IDENTIFYING IN
FIXING DANGERS BUILDINGS FROM
START TO FINISH BY BEEFING UP
LOCAL INSPECTIONS ALLOWING LOCAL
OFFICIALS TO CHARGE A FEE ALSO
TO BE A COVER THOSE INSPECTIONS.
IT ALSO ENSURES ACCOUNTABILITY
BY REQUIRING REPORTS ON
INSPECTIONS ALREADY MANDATED BY
LAW.
WHEN A DANGEROUS BUILDINGS
DISCOVERED SP FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
IMPROVES THE TOOLS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE AVAILABLE AND
REMOVES OTHER HURDLES TO
ENFORCEMENT?
ITALSO MAKES IT EASIER FOR
TENANTS AND LANDLORDS TO BRING
BUILDINGS UP TO CODE BY
DIRECTING LOCAL OFFICIALS TO
IDENTIFY SPECIFIC VIOLATIONS OF
BUILDING CODES AND OFFER ADVICE.
ON HOW TO BE A TO FIX THOSE
VIOLATIONS RENDON SIMPLY
SHUTTING IT DOWN.
BUT WE HAVE TO FANTASTIC FOLKS
WERE A KEY ALLMAN GOVERNOR FAIRS
MANGER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING OFFICIALS AS WELL AS
CARRY SIMPSON AT THE
NEIGHBORHOOD SERVICES MANAGER
FOR THE GOOD CITY OF RANCHO
CORDOVA.
WOULD INSURE --
AND I DON'T APPROPRIATE TIME
THANK YOU SO MUCH HOT MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU.
MOTION WITH THE BILL --
I WILL SECOND IT --
AND WITHOUT YOUR WITNESSES.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KATIE
ALMOND AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS
ARE CALVO.
THIS BILL IS IN ALIGNMENT WITH
CAL BOWS MISSION TO UPHOLD
HEALTH AND SAFETY WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY.
CALVET SUPPORTS THIS BILL THE
BILL AS IT WILL INCREASE
INSPECTIONS AND INDUSTRIAL
BUILDINGS INCREASING THEIR
SAFETY AND COMPLIANCE THANK YOU.
KERRY SIMPSON ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CESSATION OF COULD A
POSTMAN OFFICES --
ON BEHALF OF MY ORGANIZATION I'D
LIKE TO COMMEND SENATOR MCGUIRE
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK.
THESE BILLS SPRING FROM THE FOUR
OUT THE GHOST SHIP TRAGEDY AND
ALL IE OF MY LAW STUDY IS HAVE
DEALT WITH ISSUES LIKE THIS IN
BOTH LARGE AND SMALL COMMUNITIES
AND NOT HOW DE OF FIGHT WAY TO
DEAL WITH THEM.
SO WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER SUPPORTERS
[inaudible]
I THEIR MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE THE
BILL.
SEE NONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE --
UNLESS THERE'S ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION APPRECIATE BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD IN OBVIOUSLY
WILL HELP.
FOLKS IN THE FUTURE AVOID TRAGIC
EVENTS THAT WE DO NOT WANT TO
SEE AND HOUSING AROUND THE STATE --
AND WITH THAT I HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AYE THERE'S BEEN
A MOTION AND A SECOND ANY FINAL
COMMENTS THANK YOU SO MUCH CHAIR
WOULD RESPECT LAST WHEN I DON'T
THINK YOU CAN.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO PASS TO THE COMEDIAN
APPROPRIATIONS TO BUY CHU AYE
MAIENSCHEIN CHAU.
CHOI AYE CHOI AYE GLORIA.
LAMONT.
FREMONT I WOULD.
YOUR BILL NEEDS A COUPLE MORE
VOTES TO GET OUT --
WILL WAIT FOR ADAM MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR PRESENTATION HE SWITCHED
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND OUR FINAL BILL PRESENTATIONS
FOR THE DAY WILL BE BY SENATOR
WIECKOWSKI FILE ITEMS TO AND FOR
WHICH WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE UP
FIRST -- SP
TWELVE SIXTY THREE THE H. AWAY.
TWELVE SIXTY FIVE TWELVE SIXTY
FIVE GREAT I COULD YOU SIXTY
THREE BUT I'M.
YOU'RE HAPPY LET YOU TALK ABOUT
THE TWO IF YOU LIKE.
BOB GOOD MORNING --
BUT FIRST OFF LET ME I'VE ALL BE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AS
OUTLINED IN THE STAFF ANALYSIS
AND ITEMS NUMBER ONE AND TWO I
WILL NOT BE ACCEPTING ITEM
NUMBER THREE BECAUSE THE ISSUE
OF DEBT.
OF VALIDATION IS GOING TO BE
HANDLED JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
WHICH IS SO IT'S GOING TO BE A
REFER TO IT SHOULD I BE
SUCCESSFUL TODAY.
ARM.
I BELIEVE A S. B. THOUGHT TWELVE
SIXTY FIVE STRENGTHENS
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNANCE TO
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATION.
UNFORTUNATELY TOO MANY
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS ABUSE
ARBITRARY AND I'M JUST RULES TO
MAINTAIN THEIR POWER CONTROL
POVERTY SOCIO XIN EXCLUDING AND
DISENFRANCHISED SEEM OTHER
RESIDENTS IN THE COMMUNITY.
A WHO SEEK TO CHALLENGE THEM
BOARDS HAVE MANIPULATED
ELECTIONS BY FAILING TO NOTICE
THE ELECTION.
FAILING TO DELIVER BALLOTS ALL
THE RESIDENTS AND THROWING AWAY
BALLOTS SOMETIMES THEY DON'T
EVEN HOLD ELECTIONS WITH ME
TODAY IS A JUDGE TOM SIR WHO
ACTUALLY [inaudible]
DAY -- WITH
THE CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA EACH
AWAY LAW AS WELL AS KEVIN BAKER.
TOM WHO JUST CELEBRATED A
BIRTHDAY AND HE'S HERE WITH THE
ACLU.
THANK YOU TEAR WITNESSES.
OF MY NAME IS TOM SIR AND THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
I AM HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION LAW I'M ON THE
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CENTER IS
HERE WITH ME MARJORIE MARIE
[inaudible]
AND SEE CENTER IS DEDICATED TO
PROTECTING AND ADVANCING THE
CONSUMER AND CIVIL RIGHTS OF
HOMEOWNERS LIVING WITHIN
CALIFORNIA'S [inaudible]
FIFTY TWO THOUSAND A C. ID'S AND
AS SUCH THE CENTER CONTINUES TO
RECEIVE.
MANY COMPLAINTS FROM ALL AROUND
THE STATE ABOUT VIOLATIONS.
AND ABUSIVE PRACTICES AROUND THE
CONDUCT OF ELECTIONS
[inaudible]
AND THESE.
AB USES ARE GENERALLY A BIT
SQUELCHING ANY CHALLENGES TO THE
INCUMBENT.
BOARD -- WE
ALSO RECEIVE COMPLAINTS ON HOW
AND RESPONSE OF SOME COURTS HAVE
BEEN DO CLAIMS THAT ARE BROUGHT
BEFORE THE COURT.
ABOUT THESE ABUSES AND FOR THIS
REASON -- WE
ARE STRONGLY SUPPORTING THE BILL
A TWELVE SIXTY FIVE WHICH
ADDRESSES.
THOSE MANY A COMPLAINTS.
THAT WE HAVE.
WE SEE SO.
BEARDED AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BAKER HAPPY
BIRTHDAY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CAN BAKER FOR THE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIA ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL OF NOBODY
KNOWS BETTER THAN THIS BODY.
OF HOW IMPORTANT THE INTEGRITY
OF ELECTIONS IS TOWARD
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS AND THAT'S
TRUE IN ELECTIONS FOR THE IT
MEANT AT THE ASSEMBLY AND
LEGISLATURE'S WELL THAT IS FOR
HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS.
AND YOU CAN ONLY IMAGINE THE
MISCHIEF THAT WOULD --
BE INVITED IF THE RULES FOR
QUALIFICATION OUR ELIGIBILITY TO
RUN IS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER WERE
SUBJECT TO MANIPULATION IN THE
WAY THAT THE RULES.
CAN BE AND HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST
FOR HOMEOWNERS ASSOCIATIONS IN
FACT --
THERE ARE IN MANY CASES.
MANY MORE RULES HIGHER STANDARDS
FOR RUNNING.
FOR FOR A OF THE HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION BOARD THAN THERE ARE
FOR AS A MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY
ROOM.
SENATE WE THINK THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY VITAL HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS ARE.
A REALLY ON A GROWING AND
PORTENT FORCE IN --
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN BECAUSE THEY
CALL CARSON OF CLAUSE I
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITIES IN MANY
WAYS.
BOMB AND WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
MEASURE BY SENATOR WIECKOWSKI.
VITAL TO ENSURING THAT THESE
ELECTIONS ARE THE THAT THE
FINDINGS AND DECLARATIONS FROM
THE BILL OVER APPARENTLY BEING
DELETED BECAUSE I THINK THOSE
WHO I'M ACTUALLY DID.
FIST ARM IN SORT OF ADVANCING
THE PRINCIPLES THAT THE BILL
SOUGHT TO ENACT ON NEVERTHELESS
WE REMAIN SPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER ANY.
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT.
FEEL FREE TO STEP UP AND HIDE
STATE YOUR NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
GOOD MORNING MALLORY MICHAEL ON
BEHALF OF INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
DAVE JONES AND SUPPORT THINK YOU.
THERESA BURKE* ON BEHALF OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE ANY
MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE IT WAS
TO OPPOSE THE BILL.
ARE YOU A TWEENER [inaudible]
AT HOW TO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
EXPRESS YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
YES I WOULD THINK YOU.
ARE I'M AN INDIVIDUAL.
WITHIN A HOMEOWNERS I'VE
ACTUALLY A COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT ASSOCIATION ARE YOU
AT SUPPORTER OPPOSITE I AM IN
SUPPORT RIGHT AND WHAT IS YOUR
NAME.
MY NAME IS MARTHA AND RATIONAL.
ANYWAY FROM ADORAMA I AM FROM
THE HISTORIC TOWN OF LOCK
CALIFORNIA WHERE I OWN THE
PROPERTY [inaudible]
AND HI THERE ARE EGREGIOUS
VIOLATIONS OF THE ELECTION LAWS.
THAT HAD BEEN GOING ON SINCE TWO
THOUSAND NINE WITHIN OUR LITTLE.
UP BOARD OF DIRECTORS THAT RUNS
THE WITH THE COMMUNITY INTEREST
DEVELOPMENT THERE --
THAT THE HAVE SELF ELECTED THEIR
BOARD SEATS --
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE THEY
HAVE APPOINTED THEIR GIRLFRIENDS
THEIR MORTGAGE SHE'S AND THEIR
TENANTS TO THE BOARD AND I HAVE
KEPT ALL OTHERS OUT GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU NEED YOUR HELP
PAYING VISUAL HERE.
TESTIMONY.
EXCUSE ME SIR ARE YOU ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
IF YOU WANT TO JUST STEP TO THE
MIKE AND TELL US YOUR NAME AND
WHERE YOU'RE FROM THANK YOU I'M
FROM BURLINGAME CALIFORNIA I'M A
MEMBER OF CCHL.
AND I AM SUPPORT OF THIS OF THE
BURLINGAME ARE PARK PLAZA TOWERS
IS NOT RUN PROP PROPHYLAXIS IN
TWELVE YEARS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NOW TO THE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
OF THE COMMUNITY ASSOCIATIONS
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
ACTION COMMITTEE.
HOW WE ARE OPPOSED NOW TO S. B.
TWELVE SIXTY FIVE ONE I THINK
THE COMMITTEE AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE ANALYSIS AND THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE SUGGESTED?
THEY DO MAKE SOME POSITIVE
CHANGES TO THE BILL BUT THERE
ARE STILL SOME SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL --
WERE CONCERNED IT LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
INCREASE COSTS FOR ASSOCIATIONS
AND ULTIMATELY MORE LIKELY
SUPPRESS VOTER A PARTICIPATION.
A BECAUSE SOME OF THE CONCERNS
AND IT CREATES --
THE FIRST AND FOREMOST ON THE
INCREASING OF THE COSTS --
IT SAYS AND THE ONLY WAY THAT A
BOARD COULD DISQUALIFY MEMBER.
PURSUANT TO THE LANGUAGE RIGHT
NOW IS IF --
THROUGH ITS BYLAWS THE
ASSOCIATION I ADDED THIS
LANGUAGE WHEN UNDERSTAND WHY
THAT'S EVEN NECESSARY AS JUST AN
UNNEEDED COSTS THAT EVERY
ASSOCIATION FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
ASSOCIATIONS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WOULD HAVE TO MOVE
FORWARD AND DO.
IN ORDER TO DO A BYLAW AMENDMENT
YOU HAVE TO ACTUALLY HAVE THOSE
BY LAW MINUTES DRAFTED MOSTLY BY
AN ATTORNEY AND THEN ELECTION
HAS TO TAKE PLACE.
IF IN FACT THESE ARE GOING TO BE
THE REQUIREMENTS THEN WHY NOT
JUST MAKE THOSE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS AND RELIEVE THESE
ASSOCIATIONS OF HAVING TO DO THE
BYLAWS.
WE HAVE SAID ARE ALL ALONG THAT
WE DO THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME
OTHER AREAS OF THAT SHOULD BE
ALLOWED FOR AND THAT ASSOCIATION
SHOULD HAVE SOME FLEXIBILITY. TO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
DISQUALIFICATION.
IN THAT AREA WE WOULD BE OPEN TO
ALLOWING THAT TO BE DONE BY A
BYLAW CHANGE BECAUSE IT'S A
HIGHER BAR THERE'S GREATER
TRANSPARENCY THERE.
THERE ARE ISSUES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE --
SOME BOARDS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
HAVE THAT SPOUSES CANNOT SERVE
ON THE BOARD AT THE SAME TIME
THERE'S OTHER CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST THAT MAY OCCUR MAYBE
SOMEONE IS AN ACTIVE LITIGATION
WITH THE ASSOCIATION. TO CREATE
A SIGNIFICANT CONFLICT FOR THEM
TO BE ON THE BOARD WE THINK
THOSE TYPES OF SITUATION SHOULD
BE ALLOWED AT A LOCAL LEVEL AND
THAT THE ASSOCIATION SHOULD BE
ABLE TO DO THOSE.
THROUGH A CHANGE IN THE BYLAWS
NOT NECESSARILY A RULE.
WE AGREE THAT THE IDEA OUR ISSUE
A NEED TO BE ADDRESSED --
THEY PROVIDE THAT FOR A MEMBER
IN GOOD STANDING WOULD JUST BE
REGULAR ASSESSMENTS ARE NOTHING
ABOUT SPECIALIST US ASSESSMENTS
WHICH OCCUR.
HOT THROUGHOUT ASSOCIATIONS ARE
IN THE STATE.
NOW WRAP UP ON THE WHY WE THINK
THIS WILL SUPPRESS OUR ACTUAL
PARTICIPATION IN IN THESE
ELECTIONS THESE VOTE SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE WAY THE BILL IS RED
NOW --
MEMBERS WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO THE
VOTER REGISTRATION LIST THAT
HAVE ACCESS TO THE BALLOTS THAT
HAVE ACCESS TO THE SIGNED
ENVELOPES BASICALLY HAVE ACCESS
TO EVERY PIECE OF PAPER AND THEN
BE ALLOWED TO COPY THAT.
MOST ASSOCIATIONS IN THE STATE
AS THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT ARE
LESS THAN FIFTY UNITS.
I THESE ARE SMALL COMMUNITIES IT
DOES NOT TAKE A WHOLE LOT OF
EFFORT TO PUT THOSE BALLOTS
TOGETHER.
WITH ASSIGNED ENVELOPES AND
REALLY START TO CREATE AN
INVASION OF PRIVACY IN FACT
THERE IS LITIGATION THERE'S
COURT.
CASE OUT THERE THAT HAS HELD
THAT IN AN OWNER'S INTEREST
PRIVACY CONSTITUTIONAL INTERESTS
TO PRIVACY IS ACTUALLY A HIGHER
BAR AND ALLOWING SOMEONE ACCESS
TO THE COPYING OF THESE THESE
DOCUMENTS WE THINK AT A MINIMUM.
THAT PASSED TO BE A REMOVED TO
PROTECT THE PRIVACY INTERESTS A
OF THESE OWNERS THAT PARTICIPATE
WITHOUT THAT.
SIMPLY WILL SEE A WHOLE A WHOLE
HOST OF VOTERS.
NOT PARTICIPATE IN THESE
ELECTIONS BECAUSE OF THE FEAR
PRIVACY [inaudible]
WE SUPPORT.
UNBIASED ELECTIONS WE SUPPORT
CLEAR AND CONCISE RULES ARE
CONCERNED WITH THIS BILL RIGHT
NOW IS IT IS SO CONVOLUTED.
SO COMPLEX IT'S JUST GONNA
RESULT IN HIGHER COSTS
ADDITIONAL LITIGATION AND MORE
LIKELY MORE NON COMPLIANCE A BY
ASSOCIATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THEREFORE WE OPPOSE THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JENNIFER
WHAT ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COMMUNITY
MANAGERS --
WE APPRECIATE THE WORK OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE AMENDMENTS
THAT THE AUTHORS ACCEPTED A BUT
FOR THE REASON CA I STATED WE
WOULD ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH
THOSE COMMENTS AND WE REMAIN
OPPOSED.
RIGHT OTHER ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE AUDIENCE AND OPPOSITION.
LET'S BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY DISCUSSION.
AYE YES MISTER CHAIR YOU KNOW
IT'S HARD TO PROVE ELECTION
FRAUD IF YOU DON'T KNOW THE
UNIVERSE THE VOTERS SO YOU DON'
KNOW WHO YOU'RE STARTING WITH WE
PUT IN.
SAFEGUARDS OF THE LEADING PEOPLE
USE THE PARCEL THE HER HIGH I
COULDN'T TELL YOU WHAT MY PARCEL
NUMBER IS EVEN THOUGH I READ IT
ON MY CHECK WHAT I PAY MY
PROPERTY TAXES TWICE THE PRICE
YEARS WERE TRYING.
TO PROVIDE THAT BUT I'M WILLING
TO WORK WITH THE THE OPPOSITION
AS I HAVE THROUGHOUT THE RESERVE
PRICE OF DEMOCRACY.
YOU KNOW IF IT'S GOING TO COST
US ONE OR TWO DOLLARS FOR THESE
ELECTIONS THAT I THINK THAT
THAT'S A VALUABLE PRICE TO PAY
TO LIVE IN A HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION TO BE ABLE TO HAVE.
TO SIT BACK AND SAY EVERYBODY
PARTICIPATES IN A IN IN THE
ELECTION --
IF WE'RE SUCCESSFUL TODAY WE
MOVE ONTO JUDICIARY I WILL --
WORKED WITH THE OPPOSITION ON
WHETHER I WE CAN DO THIS
STATUTORILY OR BYLAWS AT AND YOU
KNOW I DON'T WANT TO HAVE
PACKAGES.
A UNUSUAL BECAUSE TO ME I KNOW
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
HAVE IS THAT WHILE THE AT THE
CREATION OF THE THAT HOMEOWNER
ASSOCIATIONS REQUIRED THAT THEY
HAVE ELECTION AT THE
INCORPORATION MANY OF THEM DON'T
HAVE ANY.
PROVISIONS THAT REQUIRE THEM TO
HAVE ON GOING.
YOU KNOW IF WE'RE GONNA HAVE
SOME UNIFORMITY I'M WILLING TO
TALK ABOUT THAT --
THE THRESHOLDS BUT WITH THAT I
AM I WOULD.
VIRGIN AYE VOTE.
GREAT ARAB AND WITHOUT
APPRECIATE JET YOUR WORK ON THIS
AND FOR ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND I THINK CLEARLY
WE ALL WANT TO STAND FOR OF FAIR
ELECTIONS THAT ARE TRANSPARENT --
AND THAT WORKED AND SO WITH THAT --
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL
AND HAVE A DO PASS AS AMENDED
RECOMMENDATION AND I DO KNOW
THAT THIS WILL BE GOING ON TO
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
WHERE.
A NUMBER OF US WILL HAVE ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK AT THAT SO --
WITH THAT --
I'LL TAKE THAT AS YOUR FINAL
COMMENT IT LOOKS LIKE DOCTOR
CHOI YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
I'M ASK OF SENATOR --
IN NY.
WOULD BE --
SO DIFFICULT TO LEAVE US.
OUT TO THE ELECTED BODY.
PARTS OF THE UP BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF EACH --
STUFF BICU A RULE RECESS AND
THAT THEY ARE [inaudible]
CONSTANTLY --
YEAH YOU READ ACTED.
IF THE YEAH I HAVE A PROBLEM SO
THAT THE MEMBERS SO ORDER ORDER
ORDER --
CHOOSES SOMEBODY OUTSIDE AND
THEN A CAN YOU TELL IF OFFICE
TANAKA LIVING DOCUMENT THOUGH
WHY DO WE HAVE TO GOVERN OVER
[inaudible]
THE ELECTED.
BOARD OF DIRECTORS BECAUSE IN
SOME INCIDENCES LEASE WITH THE I
SO THE CENTER FOR HOMEOWNERS
RIGHTS THEY'VE SHOWED REPEATED --
TECHNIQUES THAT HAVE BEEN USE TO
DISASSOCIATE UP PEOPLE FROM THE
ELECTORAL PROCESS JUDGE SERB
MADE BIG IF YOU MORE SPUR
[inaudible]
PACIFIC.
YES DR J. WHAT.
WHAT HAPPENS IN MANY OF THESE
ASSOCIATIONS IS THAT THE BOARD
WHICH HAS NOW HAS THE POWER TO
SET?
ANY QUALIFICATIONS WITHOUT LIMIT.
ON WHO CAN RUN FOR THE BOARD IN
THAT POWER HAS BEEN ABUSED IN A
NUMBER OF SITUATIONS THAT WE
HAVE DOCUMENTED.
AND SO ONE OF THE KEY PROVISIONS
IN THIS BILL IS IT GREATLY
LIMITS THE BASIS ON WHICH A
PERSON CAN BE DISQUALIFIED.
FROM RUNNING FOR THE BOARD THAT
IS ONE OF THE MECHANISMS OF
PRIMARY MECHANISMS HOW IN INCOME
AND BOARD REMAINS IN POWER IS
DON'T ALLOW OTHERS TO RUN.
AND THROUGH THE CHAIR I WOULD
SAY FOR THE THE GOOD ACTING IN A
DEMOCRATICALLY EMBRACING
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION THIS THIS
WILL BE A NOTHING BURGER FOR
THEM BUT FOR THE PEOPLE HAVE WHO
HAVE HAD THESE BOARDS THAT HER.
ABUSIVE AND AND AND AND NOT
ALLOWING PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN THE
SUSPECT ASSOCIATION PARTICIPATE
I THINK THIS COULD BE A
WATERSHED CHANGE OF OPERATION
AND THERE ELECTIONS.
AND WITH THAT ANY FINAL COMMENTS.
FROM LOCK TO LAFAYETTE IN LOS
ANGELES TWO WAMPOS WE NEED YOUR
HELP PLEASE. FIVE SUPPORTERS
THANK YOU THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
MOVE THE BILL BY MISTER CHILD
SECOND BY MS IMAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION TO BUSES AMENDED TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CHU AYE CHIU
AYE MAIENSCHEIN CHOW CHOW AYE
CHOI KNOW JOEY NO.
GLORIA.
LEE MON.
WE MONTH I WOULD.
YOUR BILL HAS THREE VOTES WILL
WAIT FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON
AND WITH THAT WE WILL GO TO THE
FINAL BILL ON TODAY'S AGENDA AND
THAT IS FILE ITEM TO SP.
EIGHT THIRTY ONE MISTER SENATOR
UP.
THANK YOU ARM [inaudible]
SO WHEN.
THE GOAL OF WILL BE.
WELL I GUESS.
I AM UNABLE TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED IN THE
WRITTEN REPORT THAT WILL HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION AND WE WILL GO
FORWARD AYE.
AYE.
THE GOAL OF THE S. B. EIGHT
THREE ONE AYE IS TO ELIMINATE
THE REMAINING BARRIERS TO THE
CONSTRUCTION OF ACCESSORY TWELVE
DWELLING UNITS OR A. D. U.'S.
TWO YEARS AGO I WAS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE AND S. B. ATTEND SIXTY
NINE I AM WHEN IT WENT INTO
EFFECT EIGHTY YOU PERMIT
APPLICATIONS INCREASED BY 63%
AND CALIFORNIA IN SOME AREAS
LIKE.
A MISS LIMON SAYS SANTA BARBARA
IT WAS THREE HAD OVER 3100%.
HOWEVER HUNDREDS OF HOMEOWNERS
ARE STOPPED IN THEIR TRACKS WHEN
THEY'RE HANDED A SIXTY THOU SEE
HE THOUSAND DOLLAR BILL FOR
IMPACT FEES BY THAT ME
MUNICIPALITY.
SOMETIMES THESE FEES I CAN
AMOUNT TO MORE THAN THE COST TO
THE CONVERTED GARAGE TO THE
EIGHTY YOU.
AS A RESULT PEOPLE RESORT TO
BUILDING THESE UNITS WITHOUT A
PERMIT.
IN FACT THE STUDY FOR IN SANTA
CRUZ FOUND THAT ONLY 46% OF THE
AT THE EIGHTY USE IN THIS COUNTY
HAD PERMITS.
IT'S THE 1% OF HOMEOWNERS A WITH
THESE AND PERMITTED EIGHTY YOU
CITED THAT THE FEES WAS THE
REASON FOR MOVING FORWARD
WITHOUT HAVING A PERMIT.
WE ARE PUSHING THESE UNITS INTO
THE SHADOWS BY REFUSING TO
ADDRESS THE UNTOUCHABLE FEES
THAT SOME CITIES ARE.
UP PROPOSING I HAPPEN TO
REPRESENT FREMONT FREMONT AFTER
HAVE AG ACTUALLY PRO HAVING
LISTENED TO ME FOREVER PESTICIDE
THAT THEORY PACKED IN COURT ARE
NOT GOING TO CHARGE IMPACT FEES
AS HIS SAN DIEGO.
BUT A RECENT STUDY PUBLISHED BY
THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION ESTIMATE THAT THERE
ARE THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND AND
PERMITTED EIGHTY USE IN THE
GREATER LOS ANGELES AREA ALONE
THERE'S THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
EIGHTY USE IN THE GREATER.
LOS ANGELES ON THERE'S A REASON
FOR THAT.
THERE'S A REASON WHY PEOPLE
DON'T GO TO THE PLANNING
DEPARTMENT AND GET A PERMIT THEY
AND THEY'VE NOT ACCOUNTED FOR IN
THE FIRED [inaudible] FOR A
PROPERTY ASSESSMENTS DO NOT
ACCOUNTED FOR WATER AND SEWAGE
DISTRICT THEY ARE NOT THEY DID
NOT PAY ANY IMPACT FEES.
THE BIG THEY'RE NOT PAYING ANY
PROPERTY TAXES.
BUT AND NOW.
NOBODY.
NO NOBODY SEEMS TO HAVE BROUGHT
UP WHICH AMP TRACK WERE TRYING
TO DO TODAY THE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS A PROPERTY TAXES WITH
EIGHTY YOU UNITS.
SO LET'S TAKE A MOMENT TO
BREAKDOWN OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE AVERAGE COST OF AN
EIGHTY YOU IT'S A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THE BILL.
THAT'S UNDER CONSTRUCTION THAT
DIFFERENT EDIE WAS ASSESSED AN
IMPROVEMENT IN THE PROPERTY
TAXES INCREASED BY 1% THAT'S A
VALUE OF ONE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY DOLLARS.
PER UNIT THAT IN THE IN THE
STATE.
OF LOS ANGELES HAS. THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND PERMITTED
BY UNITS SO WHAT'S TAKEN
CONSERVATISM SEE THAT'S A HALF A
MILLION UNITS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
UNDER THE CURRENT REGIME WITH
THE CITY SICK CHARGING THE
IMPACT FEES THAT THEY WANT.
THAT'S THAT'S ANNUAL TAX REVENUE
OF SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
AND I'M JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
EXISTING PERMITTED UNITS THAT'S
PART OF THE THE PROVISION IN THE
BILL THAT HAS FOR AN AMNESTY WE
WANNA HAVE SOME.
REASON FOR PEOPLE TO COME OUT OF
THE DARKNESS AND SAY I'M GOING
TO GET MY PLACE PER MINUTE NOT
TO PAY THE FULL FEE BUT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF AN AMNESTY PROGRAM.
THE IMPACT FEES TO PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE FUNDING REALLY FOR
CITIES I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
THAT BUT IF YOU HAVE NOBODY
GETTING THE PERMIT YOU'RE
GETTING A 100% BUT ZERO WHICH IS.
ZERO IT DOESN'T IT THAT THE
NUMBERS DON'T WORK OUT
ELIMINATING THE IMPACT FEES ONE
SURE THAT STEVE CONSTRUCTIONS OF
EXCESS READ WELL IN UNITS AND
CAN HELP IN OUR LONG TERM
REVENUE I'M.
WE NEED TO BE SMART ABOUT THIS
AND LOOK AT THE LONG TERM WITH
ME THAT DAY IS CORNELIUS BURKE
WITH THE BAY AREA COUNCIL AND
VIANI NAVA WHICH A CALIFORNIA.
OR SILICON VALLEY WHICH WHICH IS
ALSO IN CALIFORNIA.
ARM TEAR TO ENCOURAGE THE
SUPPORT OF S. B. [inaudible]
EIGHT THIRTY ONE I MEAN WE'VE
HAD.
HI MY NAME IS BEN AND I WITH THE
HOUSING TRUST ON THE EMAIL YOU
PROGRAM MANAGER.
THE HOUSING TRUST IF YOU DON'T
KNOW WHO WE ARE WE'RE ACTUALLY
NONPROFIT HOUSING LENDER IN THE
BAY AREA WE COVER THIRTEEN
COUNTIES --
AND WE BILL EIGHTY YOU PROGRAM
BECAUSE WE BELIEVE EIGHTY USER A
GREAT TOOL TO HELP WITH HOUSING
CRISIS ALLEVIATE THE HOUSING
CRISIS.
IT'S A MULTI GENERATIONAL TOOL
WHERE --
HOMEOWNERS CAN USE TO HOUSE SIR --
THEY'RE OLDER THEIR ADULT
CHILDREN THEIR AGING PARENTS AND
THAT THEY COULD ALSO DOWNSIZING
TO AT AND THE PROCESS TO GET IN
THAT'S DON IS OFTENTIMES
DIFFICULT AND DON TEAM AND JUST
A WHOLE OTHER LANGUAGE NOT TO
MENTION EXPENSIVE.
EXPENSE UPS ARE EIGHTY YOU
PROGRAM THAT WE'RE DEVELOPING
INCLUDES WORKSHOPS FOR EDUCATION.
AS WELL AS WE'RE COMING UP WITH
THE FINANCIAL PROGRAM TO HELP
PEOPLE GET THROUGH WHAT THE
SENATOR WAS TALKING ABOUT THESE
PERMIT FEES ARE A HUGE BARRIER
FOR HOMEOWNERS HOMEOWNERS.
STUDY AFTER STUDY HAS SHOWN THE
HOMEOWNERS ARE VERY EXCITED TO
BUILD EIGHTY YOU BECAUSE ALL OF
THESE BENEFITS AND THAT CAN BILL
WELL FOR THEM.
BUT ONCE THEY GET THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND THEY'RE TRYING TO
PULL HE WOULD YOU BILL --
OFTENTIMES BE --
AS HIGH AS 10% OF THE TOTAL
DEVELOPMENT COST AND SO IT'S A
HUGE BURDEN NOT JUST
ECONOMICALLY BUT I THINK ALSO
PSYCHOLOGICAL --
TO GET THROUGH THIS I THINK
THERE'S THROUGH OUR PROGRAM
WOULD BE TALKING TO HOMEOWNERS
WHO WE FOUND MORE AND MORE OFTEN
THAT WHEN I ASK HOMEOWNER WHY
THEY WANT TO BUILD.
THIS BECAUSE I WANT TO BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION SO HERE'S A
HOMEOWNER THAT MAYBE DOESN'T
HAVE ALL THESE OTHER NEEDS LIKE
OTHER PEOPLE THEY WANT TO BE
PART OF THE SOLUTION.
THEY GO DOWN TO THE PLANNING
DEPARTMENT AND BUILDING AND
SUMMIT AND THEN THEY GET A HUGE
BELL AND I THINK THAT
PSYCHOLOGICAL.
PSYCHOLOGICALLY IT BECOMES A
BARRIER OF LIKELY I'M TRYING TO
DO SOMETHING GOOD AND YOU'RE
ACTUALLY DECIDE TO BUY FROM YOU
FROM DOING THAT LIKE IF THEY
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S GONNA BE
CONSTRUCTION COST BUT I THINK A
LOT OF HOMEOWNERS FEEL LIKE I'M.
THE CITY SHOULD BE SUPPORTING
THEM -- AND
SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY
TO TALK ABOUT THAT THE IMPACT
FEES AS A BEAR TO BUILDING.
EIGHTIES.
THEREFORE THE HOUSING TRUST
SUPPORTS S. B. EIGHT THIRTY ONE
WHICH PROPOSES TO ELIMINATE
ELEMENT IMPACT FEES IN CAP
SCHOOLS ARE THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
WE FIND THAT THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLE --
IMPORTANT SOLUTION FOR THE
PRODUCTION OF IDIOTS FIGURE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CORNELIUS BURKE WITH THE
BAY I'LL BET THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL REPRESENT THREE HUNDRED
THE TOP EMPLOYERS IN THE BAY
AREA REGION.
OUR COMPANIES ARE TELLING US IS
YOU KNOW THAT'S HOW THE CRISIS
REALLY MAKE IT QUITE DIFFICULT
TO FIND.
TRACK AND RETAIN TALENT A WE
HAVE A HOUSING CRISIS WHAT WE
NEED TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY OF
HOUSING. EIGHTY WAS GETS US
THERE WE ALSO HAVE BOLD AND
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS
IN THE STATE WHEN YOU REDUCE THE
VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED.
HAVE REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES ARE
EIGHTY SMART DELICATE INFILL
DEVELOPMENT.
ALSO WE TALK ABOUT LOCAL
DISPOSAL LOCAL LOCAL LOCAL BILL.
I GIVES POWER BACK TO THE
HOMEOWNERS THAT YOU CAN ANY MORE
LOCAL THAN THAT --
FOR THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL REQUEST WE
ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LET ME ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
CAN.
HATE THAT MAKE.
I NEVER SEVERE REVENGE I AM
HOMEOWNER --
WHO WOULD BENEFIT ENORMOUSLY
FROM S. B. --
EIGHT THIRTY ONE THE NEW LAWS
REGARDING EIGHTY USE HAVE
ALREADY HELPED PUSH ME FROM THE
CAMP OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD NOT
CONSIDER BUILDING AN EIGHTY YEAR
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE VERY
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT BUILDING
EIGHTY USE --
I REALLY BELIEVE THAT HAVING A
REGULATIONS IN PROTECTIONS AND
FRANKLY JUST PRESS AT THE STATE
LEVEL -- IS
REALLY CRITICAL FOR HOMEOWNERS
LIKE ME TO FEEL LIKE THEY'RE
DOING SOMETHING THAT'S
LEGITIMATE AND NOT UNDER THE
TABLE A PUBLIC MOST OF MY
NEIGHBORS HAVE DONE IN THE PAST --
SOMETHING THAT HASN'T BEEN
MENTIONED BUT THAT'S A PART OF
THIS BILL IS TAKING OUT THE LOOK
A LOT COVERAGE --
WHICH IS REALLY CRITICAL FOR
PEOPLE LIKE ME WHO MIGHT HAVE
SMALLER LOTS --
WHERE THE CITY IS LIKE REALLY
DETERMINE THEIR PLANNING
DEPARTMENTS DON'T WANT YOU TO
PUT SOMETHING BACK THERE --
AND THEY USE LIGHT AREA COVERAGE
AS A WAY TO BLOCK THAT SO I
CANNOT.
REALLY CRITICAL --
ALSO THE PARKING REQUIREMENTS
OPEN UP POSSIBILITIES --
IT'S LIKE I HAVE A REALLY OLD
GRUDES TOTALLY UNCLEAR WHETHER
IT'S ONE SPACE FOR TWO SPACES IN
THE PLANNING DEPARTMENT WILL USE
THAT TO SAY.
I CAN'T BELIEVE NAY YOU UNLESS
THEY REPLACED THE GARAGE AND YOU
KNOW I CAN AFFORD TO PUT DOWN A
SLAB AND PUT DOWN A PREFAB EDU I
CANNOT AFFORD TO ALSO REALLY
ASKING MY ENTIRE YARD PUT IN A
NEW GARAGE AND IN YOUR DRIVEWAY --
I ALSO REALLY APPRECIATE THE AT
THE TIME LIMIT --
THAT THE PLANNING DEPARTMENT IS
REQUIRED TO HAVE --
I HAVE NEIGHBORS WITH NIGHTMARE
STORIES ABOUT --
PLANNING DOCUMENTS GETTING LOST
AND EVEN JUST HAVING A TIME
LIMIT SO LIFE SOME IDEA OF HOW
LONG THE PROCESS MIGHT TAKE AT
THE PLANNING LEVEL --
HELP ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE
STRESS OF THE PROCESS BECAUSE IT
PUTS ANOTHER KNOWN IN THEIR IN.
I MEAN ENDING POINTS BACKED WHAT
VA SAID I WANT TO BE A PART OF
THE SOLUTION TO THE HOUSING
CRISIS --
THOSE FEES ARE A HUGE EMOTIONAL
AND PSYCHOLOGICAL BARRIER I WANT
TO GO OUT AND I WANT TO DO
SOMETHING GOOD --
AND ON TOP OF THAT ACTUALLY NEED
THE INCOME MY MY PARTNER IS SEC --
AND AYE LOSSES INCOME LAST YEAR
AND SO IN ORDER TO KEEP OUR
HOUSE -- I
REALLY NEED TO FIND ANOTHER
SOURCE OF INCOME AND IN EIGHTY
YOU WOULD BE A GREAT WAY TO DO
THAT BUT THE FEES THAT ARE HAVE
TO PAY ON TOP OF THE UNIT ITSELF.
ARE A MASSIVE BARRIER TO ME
ACTUALLY --
FOR TO BE PROFITABLE FOR ME TO
BUILD THE EIGHTY SO I AM I
REALLY SUPPORT SB EIGHT THIRTY
ONE IT WOULD BE ENORMOUSLY
HELPFUL THANK YOU.
MORNING LEAH SILVERTHORNE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MICHAEL
MCLAUGHLIN A VOLUNTEER WITH
EIGHTY HARD P. A. R. P. SUPPORTS
S. B. A THIRTY ONE AND YOUR MUSE
FISHER WITH THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBERS POSES CUBA FOR
THIS EMPHASIS KOBE REPLICAS OF
THE TRIP IN SUPPORT.
LOUIS MONTANA BE HAVE OF
CALIFORNIA BE AS ONE OF THE
THINK THE CHAIR AND AND AND THE
SENATOR FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THIS ISSUE.
AYE I WANTED ENCOURAGED
COMPROMISE SPECIFICALLY ON THIS
FEE QUESTION.
ON SOME SOME WATER DISTRICTS
LIKE THIS VOCAL WATER. THOUSAND
AND FOURTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
JUST FOR THAT THE CONNECTION --
THAT THAT IN PREDICTABILITY IN
THAT THAT HI FI ACTS AS A REAL
BARRIERS WE'VE HEARD AYE TO
HOMEOWNERS --
ACCESS SAYING YOU KNOW THEIR
THEIR THEIR OWN BACKYARD IS
ADDITIONAL REVENUE SOURCE TO
KEEP THEM IN THEIR HOME.
AYE WE WE SEE EIGHT THREE ONE IS
A REALLY IMPORTANT WAY.
I WANT ONE REALLY IMPORTANT
STRATEGY FOR SOLVING THE STATE'S
HOUSING CRISIS WHICH THE
COMMITTEE IS THAT QUITE AWARE OF
A AS WELL AS AN IMPORTANT
STRATEGY FOR ATTAINING
HOMEOWNERSHIP ARE AMONG THOSE
WHO CURRENTLY HAVE.
I JUST WONDERED URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF A THREE ONE AND I
THINK EVERYBODY FOR ALL THEIR
WORK.
JENNIFER SECOND HALF CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS IN
SUPPORT FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED.
ASSISTANCE AND I'M GAP THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION.
TIFFANY FAN OF HAVE A BRIDGE
HOUSING SUPPORT.
MARJORIE MURRAY CENTER FOR
CALIFORNIA HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION
LAW IN SUPPORT WE THANK THE
SENATOR FOR BRINGING FORTH THIS
MEASURE.
GOOD MORNING MISS SHARON MEMBERS
AND COMMUNISTS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES JUMPING IN HERE IS A
NEUTRAL IF I COULD JUST TO MAKE.
A COMMENT --
WE WOULD NEUTRALIZE LARGE PART
BECAUSE OF THE SENATOR AND AND
STAFF IN THE HARD WORK THEY PUT
IN COMMITTEE STAFF AS WELL.
JUST ONE TO POINT OUT THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED.
YOUR IN THE BILL THAT --
DESPITE THE AGREEMENT WE'VE
WE'VE REACHED WHERE FEES I AM IT
THAT THE CURRENT LANGUAGE DOES
EXPANDED THE LIST OF EIGHTY USE
THAT WOULD BE EXEMPT FROM THOSE
FEES THE WAY IT'S DRAFTED SO I
WE'VE SUBMITTED LANGUAGE TO
COMMITTEE STAFF AND AND THE
AUTHORS OFFICE. TO ADDRESS THAT
WE THINK IT SAID A TECHNICAL FIX
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD ADDRESS
THAT CONCERN.
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU --
LET ME ASK IF THERE'S OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
WE CAN MAKE SOME ROOM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SCHEMES
WANTING AS MUCH OR IF.
CHAIR MEMBERS NVIDIA WITH THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING AND UNFORTUNATELY WE DO --
REMAIN OPPOSED --
THE SCHOOL FACILITY PROGRAM IN
CALIFORNIA IS BASED ON THREE
THINGS RIGHT STATE.
BONDS LOCAL BONDS AND DEVELOPER
IMPACT FEES AND SO OBVIOUSLY OF
THIS HAS A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
SCHOOLS ABILITY --
TO MEET THEIR STUDENT HOUSING
NEEDS AND SO --
AND ALSO --
PROPOSITION FIFTY ONE WAS
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND THAT DID
JOB A LOT THE SCHOOL FACILITY
PROGRAM IT AT A WHICH INCLUDES A
OF THE FEES --
IN AND IS NOT SUPPOSED TO BE A
CHANGE SO --
FOR THOSE REASONS --
WE CONTINUE TO REMAIN OPPOSED
AND CERTAINLY WE THOUGHT THE THE
ANALYSIS --
IDENTIFIED THE OF THE CORRECT
APPROACH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
AND CHRIS LEE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION I DO WANNA POINTOUT
THAT WE AGREE WITH THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS AND THOSE
WOULD GO A LONG WAY TOWARDS
ADDRESSING OUR CONCERNS WITH
THIS BILL.
BUT OUR CONCERNS DO EXTEND
ACTUALLY BR SO FIRST I WANT TO
ECHO THAT THE BROAD CONCERN
ABOUT PLACING ESSENTIALLY AN
ARBITRARY RESTRICTION ON IMPACT
FEES THAT THAT THE SCHOOLS HAVE
CHF.
JUST BROUGHT UP ON THESE ARE IS
ESSENTIALLY SECOND HOMES THAT
ARE BEING ADDED TO PARCELS AND
IN COUNTY WORLD PEOPLE ARE
PAYING IMPACT FEES TO SUPPORT
LIBRARIES TO SUPPORT PARKS TO
PORT SHARE OF STATIONS.
SUPPORT ALL OF THESE PUBLIC
GOODS THAT WE KNOW PEOPLE NEED
IF THEY'RE GOING TO BE MOVING
INTO A NEIGHBORHOOD AND
INCREASING THE NEED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SERVICE SAYS.
NOT TO MENTION ROADS WHERE WE
JUST PASSED A BILL LAST YEAR S.
B. ONE THAT INCLUDES AN
INCENTIVE FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO CHARGE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION IMPACT FEES TO
HELP BRING THE LOCAL REVENUES
INTO THE SYSTEM --
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FEW
LIMITATIONS I THINK THERE'S BEEN
SORT OF A AN IMPRESSION GIVEN
HERE THAT THESE VIEWS ARE
ARBITRARILY CREATED AND THAT'S
NOT THE CASE.
WE HAVE THE MITIGATION FEE ACT
WHICH REQUIRES THAT THESE FEES
BE LINKED TO THE ACTUAL IMPACTS
THAT ARE CREATED --
IF FEES ARE BEING CHARGED RIGHT
NOW 280- USE THAT ARE NOT
PROPORTIONATE TO THEIR IMPACTS
THAT WE SHOULD THROW THE BOOK AT
THOSE PEOPLE WE SHOULD REQUESTED
JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE AUDIT.
AND GET TO THE BOTTOM OF WHY THE
FEES ART AND ACTUALLY
PROPORTIONATE TO THE SIZE OF THE
UNIT OR THE NUMBER OF BEDROOMS
TO THE ACTUAL INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPACTS THAT ARE HAPPENING.
AND SO WE WERE JUST GOING TO
CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE IN THE LAW
AND SAY THAT THESE FEES MUST BE
PROPORTIONATE THAT'S SOMETHING
WE SHOULD SUPPORT AND IT'S NOT
SOMETHING.
WHERE AND YOU KNOW THAT'S THAT
THAT SHOULDN'T BE HAPPENING
UNDER EXISTING LAW EVEN --
ASIDE FROM THE FEE ISSUE WE DO
HAVE SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS ABOUT
SOME HEALTH AND SAFETY ISSUES
THAT ARE ALSO INCLUDED IN THIS
BILL.
SECTION THREE OF THE BILL IS
ESSENTIALLY THE EXCEPTION THAT
EIGHT THE ROLE SO WHILE SECTION
ONE AND THE OTHER PARTS OF THE
BILL.
ALLOW US TO PRECLUDE EXCEPT
THREE DWELLING UNITS BASED ON
HEALTH AND SAFETY REASONS FOR
INSTANCE WE'VE SEEN SEVERAL
LOCAL ORDINANCES THAT PRECLUDE
EIGHTY USE IN HIGH FIRE HAZARD
SEVERITY ZONES WE'VE SEEN
SEVERAL LOCAL ORDINANCES LOS
ANGELES COUNTY FOR INSTANCE JUST
APPROVED BEARS.
THAT PRECLUDES EIGHTY USE AND
HEALTH SITE MANAGEMENT ZONES
WHERE LANDSLIDES OR COMMENT
ESPECIALLY IF YOU ALSO HAVE A
FIRE AND THAT'S HAPPENED AND SO
WE THINK IT'S AGAINST GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY TO PRECLUDE.
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM
LIMITING FOR HEALTH AND SAFETY
REASONS WHERE THOSE TYPES OF
EIGHTY USE LISTED IN SECTION
THREE OF THE BILL CAN ACTUALLY
BE PLACED.
SO UNDER SECTION THREE OF THE
BILL WE WOULD HAVE TO ALLOW BY
RIGHT ON ANY PARCEL THAT HAS A
SINGLE FAMILY HOME EXISTING.
STAND ALONE EIGHT HUNDRED SQUARE
FOOT EIGHTY YOU UP TO TWO EIGHTY
USE ON A MULTI FAMILY PARCEL
WITH AND HOUSING AS WELL AS
CONVERSIONS WHICH ARE ALREADY BY
RIGHT.
AND THERE'S ALSO WE'RE WE'RE NOT
AS CONCERNED ABOUT THIS BUT
THERE'S ALSO THE CONVERSION OF
EXISTING SPACE WITH AND MULTI
FAMILY DWELLING UNITS.
SO AT THE VERY LEAST WE NEED TO
HAVE THE SAME ABILITY TO
PRECLUDE THOSE BY RIGHT SORT OF
DEFAULT EIGHTY USE IN SECTION.
THREE THAT WE DO IN THE REST OF
OUR ORDINANCES BECAUSE THE WAY
IT FUNCTIONS NOW IS IT'S REALLY
AN EXCEPTION THAT UNDERMINES ALL
THE OTHER PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THE BILL --
FINALLY I WANT TO SAY THAT. FOR
APPROVAL AND WE CAN ACCEPT AN
ACCELERATED TIME FRAME AND I
THINK WE'VE INDICATED TO THIS
AUTHOR OF NOT IN MY DEFENSE OF
THE OTHER TWO EIGHTY YUBA
AUTHORS.
AND THAT WE COULD ACCEPT A
NINETY DAYTIME FRAME IF IT
REQUIRES SUBMISSION OF A
COMPLETE APPLICATION.
ON AND THAT'S ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT IN THIS --
INSTANCE WHERE THERE'S A DEEMED
APPROVED REMEDY IN THE BILL AND
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED AS I MENTIONED THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WOULD BE I
THINK A GREAT STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
ON I THINK WE CAN HAVE A BROADER
CONVERSATION THAT WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE NEXT YEAR WHEN EACH C. D.
COMPLETES THE ANALYSIS OF THE
MITIGATION FEE ACT THAT WAS
REQUIRED BY AB EIGHT SEVENTY
NINE FROM LAST YEAR'S
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE.
BUT UNTIL THAT TIME WE THINK
IT'S PREMATURE AND AGAINST GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY TO ARBITRARILY
PRECLUDE THESE NEW SECOND UNITS
FROM PAYING THE IMPACT FEES THAT
SUPPORT THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND FACILITIES THAT THE
RESIDENTS THERE BONNIE THANK YOU.
SARAH ROGERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION IN
SUPPORT OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS AMENDMENTS.
JEFF RIGHTLY CALIFORNIA CITIES
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL I'M JUST VERY BRIEFLY ON
THE FEES SOME REALLY CLEARED AB
AGREE WITH WHAT DOES HE SEC
MENTION HE'S WRITTEN ABOUT
MITIGATION FEE ACT IT IS ILLEGAL
FOR A CITY. TO CHARGING A FEE
BASED ON MITIGATION FEE ACT IF
THAT HE'S GONNA THEN GO TO THE
GENERAL FUND THE FUNDS CAN ONLY
BE USED FOR THE SERVICES THERE
REALLY DEMANDED BY THOSE WHO
RESIDE IN THAT NEW EIGHTY YOU.
I'M IN BUT WE ARE PURPOSES.
ORINDA VALENCIA REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
ALSO OPPOSED IN WHAT I CALL THE
COMMENTS RAISED AND JUST ONE AD
WE DO APPRECIATE THAT.
A REFERENCE TO THE AND NATIONAL
POLICY A STUDY THAT WAS DONE --
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE A
LOT OF CHANGES IN THIS BILL
BEYOND FEES I'M AND THIS IS THE
THIRD YEAR IN A ROW OR LOOKING
AT MAJOR CHANGES SOMETHING.
YEAH LAST YEAR.
KELLY BRICKS ON BEHALF OF THE
ROLE COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
POSITION AND WE WOULD ECHO THE
COMMON IT'S ABOUT SUPPORTING ON
THAT A COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU.
DAVID JONES ABAFT THE CITIES OF
BURBANK THE CITIES OF MARIN.
CITY IS OF ME PERIODIC AND SAN
MARCOS ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT
LEAVING MY FRIENDS FROM CAESAR.
ALICE KESSLER ON BEHALF OF JUST
ONE CITY CITY OF LONG BEACH ALSO
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION.
KATIE ALMOND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING OFFICIALS OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE AND I'LL START OFF
WITH SOME COMMENTS --
FIRST OF ALL A FOR A COLLEAGUES
I WANNA JUST --
LAY OUT A COUPLE OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE DISCUSSED AND A SENATOR
AND I I THINK WE'VE HAD FOR
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS.
AND YOU'VE BEEN ABLE FOR IF NOT
MORE THINK FOR AND OUR STAFF
HAVE HAD PROBABLY --
SEVERAL DOZEN POT AND I THINK
IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT YOU HAVE
WON ME OVER ON MANY THE MINUTES
THAT WE DISCUSSED LAST WEEK --
WITH ONE EXCEPTION AND THAT IS
THE FEE ISSUE AND I RAISE THAT
TO SAY THAT I THINK WHERE I AM
AND WHERE THE SENATOR ARE WE
AGREE ON 95% OF THIS BILL.
ARE AND IT'S JUST THAT ONE LAST
PIECE THAT WE ARE --
LITTLE BIT STUCK ON AND I'LL
JUST SAY IN THE STAFF ANNOUNCES
THIS BILL DOES SIXTEEN THINGS
AND UP THE ONE ISSUE THAT --
THAT I KNOW YOU FOCUSED YOUR
TESTIMONY ON WHICH WAS THAT THE
FEAR SHE WAS THE ONE THAT WE'RE
WE'RE GRAPPLING WITH AND I SAY
THAT BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
THIS BILL DOES A LOT OF THINGS
WE ARE ASKING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO DO A LOT OF THINGS AND I
THINK.
IT THIS TIME UP WITHOUT FURTHER
ANALYSIS OUGHT TO SAY THAT --
WITH THAT WITH JUST THE CAP ON
SCHOOL FEES AND A WITH THE
ISSUES WITH RELATED TO UTILITIES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CANNOT --
ASK ANY OTHER FEES.
I'M I'M NOT COMPLETELY CONVINCED
THAT THE RIGHT ANSWER IS ZERO
NOW I WILL SAY THAT I AGREE WITH
YOU.
THAT THERE DO APPEAR TO BE
JURISDICTIONS WHERE THE FEES ARE
TOO HIGH --
BUT THAT IS WHY LAST YEAR AS
PART OF THE HOUSING PACKAGE WE
SUPPORTED AB EIGHT SEVENTY NINE
WHICH WILL REQUIRE A STUDY OF
THE IMPACT FEES TO COME BACK. TO
THIS LEGISLATURE SO THAT WE CAN
RESOLVE THESE ISSUES I THINK WE
WILL LIKELY HAVE A VERY ROBUST
CONVERSATION NEXT YEAR ABOUT ALL
HOUSING IMPACT FEES AND I'M JUST
WORRIED.
THAT DEALING WITH THIS AND AND
IN A IN SUCH A BIFURCATED WAY
FULL ANALYSIS.
I THINK IT'S A BIT PREMATURE OUT
ALSO SAY THIS COMMITTEE --
SEVERAL WEEKS AGO WE HAD
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TEAMS BILL WHICH
YOU KNOW IS A BILL THAT IS A
COMPANION BILL TO THIS.
ONE AYE AND WE HAD ASKED HIM TO
TAKE THOSE.
A REQUIREMENTS OUT AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT THIS COMMITTEE
DID.
AND SO I THINK OUT OF
CONSISTENCY WOULD MAKE SENSE TO
DO THAT THAT BEEN SAID YOU KNOW
YOU WE JUST WE'VE DISCUSSED OF
THE LAST FEW DAYS SOME WAY TO
TRY TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
PROPORTIONALITY FEES WOULD LOOK
LIKE WE JUST HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO COME UP WITH LANGUAGE --
I'M OPEN TO CONTINUE THAT
CONVERSATION THROUGH THE PROCESS --
IN IN THE COMING WEEKS IF WERE
ABLE TO GET THERE A BUT I THINK
AT THIS TIME THE IDEA OF JUST
SIMPLY TAKING ALL THE FEES OUT --
GIVEN ALL THE THINGS THAT THIS
BILL IS TRYING TO DO IS A LITTLE
PREMATURE AND I WILL JUST SAY
JUST TO SUMMARIZE.
THIS BILL IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ANALYSIS IT REQUIRES LOCAL
AGENCIES TO POTENTIALLY
DESIGNATE AREAS WERE EIGHTY USE
MAY BE EXCLUDED FOR HEALTH AND
SAFETY REASONS.
SAYS AT LOCAL AGENCIES CAN'T
ESTABLISH STANDARDS AROUND
MINIMUM LOT SIZES --
REFERENCES SQUARE FOOTAGE IS A
PROPOSED EIGHTY USE MINIMUM
MAXIMUM SIZES FOR EIGHTY YEARS
SETBACKS GARAGES CARPORTS NAM
APPLICATION TIME FRAMES --
I COULD GO ON AND ON ABOUT WHAT
THIS BILL DOES AND WHAT THIS
BILL IS GOING TO DO IS IT LAYERS
MANY ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHICH I
SUPPORT.
BUT AGAIN THE IDEA OF SAYING
WE'RE GONNA LAYER ALL THESE
REQUIREMENTS --
BUT SAY THAT LOCALS ARE UNABLE
TO RECOUP ANY OF IT THAT'S
WHAT'S GIVING ME A LITTLE BIT
HARPER SO ODD RABBIT YOU KNOW
HAVING DISCUSSION YOU KNOW I'VE
HAD A COUPLE TIMES BUT I JUST
WANTED TO SAY ALL THAT.
LET ME TRY TO NARROW THE THE
WINDOW THAT THAT THAT I THINK
THE ADVOCATE WHO IS REFLECTIVE
THE ADVOCATES IN IN THE SPIRIT
OF AB EIGHT SEVENTY NINE BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT GONNA COME BACK TO US
NEXT.
NEXT YEAR AND PROBABLY NOT COULD
HAVE REGULATIONS TILL TWENTY
TWENTY ONE OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT IF IT IF IT IF IF THEY COME
BACK WITH RECOMMENDATIONS SO WE
BRAG BECAUSE THAT'S THAT THE THE
THE STUDY SUPPOSED TO COME BACK
NEXT YEAR SO WE COULD ACTUALLY.
LA WE COULD ACTUALLY TAKE MAKE
DECISION.
OKAY EXACT I'M HOPING TO ALL TO
SAY THAT FOR EVERYONE WHO.
NOW THERE'S A MOVE HOPE THAT WE
DON'T BUT SO THE POINT OF ASKING
THE STUDY TO COME BACK NEXT YEAR
TO GIVE US THE OPPORTUNITY
HERE'S MY CONCERN IN THE MATCH --
WHETHER YOU AGREE WITH ME THAT
THERE'S FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
AND PERMITTED UNITS ARE NOT
THERE'S STILL A WHOLE HECK OF A
LOT OF FUN PER MINUTE YOU.
AND AND AND THERE'S NO REASON TO
HAVE AN AMNESTY PROGRAM IF THEY
HAVE TO PAY FULL PRICE FOR THE
PERMITS THAT THEY HAVE THEY'RE
NOT PAYING PROPERTY TAXES AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE COUNT THAT WE
THAT OUR HOUSING ELEMENTS AND
EVERYTHING HAS.
SO IF WE'RE ALLOWED TO HAVE A
HAVE THE THE WAIVER OF THE FEES
UNTIL WE TAKE SUCH ACTION AND
THEN THAT WOULD BE WITH THE
RESULT OF AB.
SEVEN NINE A EIGHT SEVEN NINE
AND THERE'S A THERE'S A
CONSENSUS IN LEGISLATION THAT
THE GOVERNOR --
SIGNS THEM WHAT WE WILL BE DOING
IS IS IS WILL HAVE A YEAR OR
EIGHTEEN MONTHS OR TWO YEARS
THAT THERE WOULD BE THIS WINDOW
SO THAT ALL THE BOOTLEG UNITS
WOULD KNOW THAT THEY HAVE TO GO
NOW.
OR THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SEE
THAT.
AT CPAP PAY THE FEE ADDITIONALLY
ALL BE ABLE TO SHOW AT THAT TIME
HOW MANY OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE
COME ONLINE AND ARE PAYING THE
PROPERTY TAXES.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW AGAIN THESE WE
WEEK CONVENIENTLY FORGET THE
FIRST WORD OF THE THE FEES WERE
TALKING ABOUT IS DEVELOPER
IMPACT FEES.
THE SERVER HOMEOWNERS THEIR PAIN
THE IMPACT FEES THEY'RE TREATING
THEM THE ALL OF THEM ARE
TREATING THEM LIKE THEY'RE
DEVELOPERS BUT THEY'RE NOT
DEVELOPERS HERE'S THEIR OUR
NEIGHBORS OUR CONSTITUENTS THAT
ARE PUTTING IN A SECOND UNIT.
THEY'RE NOT A DEVELOPER IMPACT
FEE SO IN THAT SPIRIT I GET IT
WHEN YOU COME IN YOUR EACH WEEK
CAN BE HOMES THAT'S A WHOLE
DIFFERENT THING BUT BUT WE'VE
ALLOWED THE SCHOOLS AND THE
COUNTIES.
AND SPECIAL DISTRICTS TO TREAT
THESE.
AS THOUGH THEIR DEVELOPERS AND
WE'VE HEARD IT INSTEAD AND
PREVIOUS SO.
I KNOW THAT THAT IS A BIG LEAP
FOR ME TOOK A TO TAKE BUT BUT
I'D AT LEAST.
MAYBE ALL BE WRONG AND WILL HAVE
THIS WINDOW OF TIME WHATEVER IT
IS TO TAKE TO IT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS ANYTHING FEES
I'M WILLING.
TO FALL ON THE SWORD AND SAY
I'VE I FEEL SO --
DRIVEN THAT I NEED I NEED TO
SHOW THAT THESE FOLKS CAN COME
OUT AND WE CAN ACTUALLY.
ADDRESS THE HOUSING ISSUES THAT
THAT ALL LIVE WITH EVERITT
WHATEVER THE AT EACH CD COMES
OUT ON WHAT THEY BELIEVE WILL BE
THE IMPACT THE IMPACT FEES ON
EIGHTY USE THAT WOULD BE THAT
BECOME THE STATE LAW WHATEVER
THAT NUMBER IS.
AND GIVE ME A SMALL WINDOW OF
TIME TO TO SEE IF WE CAN GET
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE UNDER THE
AMNESTY PROGRAM.
A COME FORWARD INTO LEGITIMATELY
PARTICIPATE IN THE COMMUNITY THE
COMMUNITIES THAT'S I I THINK
THAT THAT'S THAT THAT'S FAIR
BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A BARRIER
THAT'S OUT THERE AND I REALLY I
UNDERSTAND THE CHAIR AND AND THE
COUNTIES IN EVERYBODY'S.
INTERESTED IN HAVING MORE
HOUSING A A UP THERE IN THE ACT
BY.
I DO THAT WITH THE GREATEST
RESPECT FOR THE CHAIR IN THE
GREATEST RESPECT FOR THE WORK
THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS DONE FOR
THIS SMALL WINDOW UNTIL THEY
MAKE THEIR DECISION AND WE THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED INTO LAW WHAT
THE NEW FEES ARE GOING TO BE FOR
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNITS WHICH I
THINK.
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR.
SO WHAT I'M HEARING YOU SAYING
IS THE POTENTIAL SMALL WINDOW
THAT THAT'S NOT AN IDEA THAT.
I I KNOW WE HAD DISCUSSED THAT
SO I GUESS I WOULD LIKE ON IT.
I SLEPT ON A COUCH AND WE DID
HAVE A CHANCE RIGHT WE DON'T
JUST TALK THIS MORNING ELIMINATE
LET ME LET ME SAY A FEW THINGS
AND RESPONSE --
I KNOW YOU CHARACTERIZE THIS AS
HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE ARE TRYING TO
BUILD EXTRA HOME THAT IS THE
CASE WITH WITH MOST.
OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT BUT
WE ARE NOT ASKING YOU TO TAKE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD HAVE
REQUIRED AN OWNER OCCUPIED.
REQUIREMENT WHICH DOES ME
[inaudible]
MANY MANY.
MANY MANY AND LAW UNITS I IN
WE'RE NOT ASKING FEE.
THERE ARE THAT FEELS A LITTLE
BIT -- FEELS
A LITTLE BIT STRANGE WE ALSO
KNOW IT WAS ALIVE.
WE ALSO KNOW AT THIS TIME THERE
ARE CITIES THAT HAVE CHOSEN
BECAUSE THEY'VE MADE THE
CALCULATION LIKE THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO.
OUGHT TO OUGHT TO WEIGH FEES TO
HAVE AN AMNESTY AND I THINK THAT
IF LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
ARE DECIDED THAT THAT WAS THE
RIGHT POLICY BECAUSE THEY WOULD
EXPECT TO SEE MORE IN PROPERTY
TAXES.
ARE THEY CAN GO AHEAD AND DO IT
THERE'S NOTHING THAT PREVENTS A
LOCAL CITY.
A CITY FROM FROM MOVING FOR
DOING THAT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
RIGHT NOW THOUGH IS THAT THIS IS
A ONE SIZE FITS ALL LET'S.
ELIMINATE ALL FEES FOR ALL
JURISDICTIONS OUTSIDE OF THE TWO
CATEGORIES THAT YOU ENUMERATED
IN AGAIN FOR THAT'S WHAT WINDOW
FOR A SMALL WINDOW OF TIME.
UNTIL THE LEGISLATURE ACCENT
EACH ARE A CD.
ROD RECOMMENDATIONS SO THAT IT
WOULD BE TIME WHAT IS TIME
SENSITIVE WE WOULD PUT AMEND
THIS BILL SO THAT WHEN THAT
BECAME THE LAW WE WOULD PUT IT
IN.
AND AND AGAIN WE IT RATHER THAN
FOCUS ON THAT THE FAIR CITIES
HAVE A FEE THAT THAT THAT SEEMS
TO BE AT ANOTHER THEY'RE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO WORK WITH ME
AND WORK WITH THE ADVOCATES
THERE A LOT OF CITIES THAT ARE
USED IN THE FEES.
SIMPLY AS A WAY TO DISCOURAGE
THE EIGHT ACT EIGHTY USE WE WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN A HISTORY --
THROUGHOUT THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS THERE THERE AREN'T ANY
EIGHTY USE THAT EARLY HOLD THAT
BILL I MEAN THERE'S A UP HANDFUL
OF THEM THE MOST OF THEM DO NOT
GET PERMITS THERE'S A REASON WHY
PEOPLE HAVEN'T DONE DONE THAT.
IN IF WE JUST IF WE JUST
CONTINUE WITH THAT ALLOW THE HOW
COME THE BAD ACTORS CITIES AND
THE AND THE OTHER CITIES IF IF
THEY COME TO JESUS AND THEY
CHANGE THE FEES WERE NOT NOT
GOING TO HAVE THAT.
THAT DESIRABILITY OF OF HAVING
HOMEOWNERS BUILD THINGS AND
AGAIN I THINK IN THE LONG
PICTURE THE CITIES IN THE
SCHOOLS ARE GOING TO BE MADE
WHOLE BECAUSE IT WHO THAT TAX
INCREMENT IS GOING TO BE.
COMPORT AND THAT'S ON ME THAT'S
ON ME WHEN I EIGHT CD COMES AND
SO.
THAT'S MY PLEA SO.
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION AS
AS I'VE SAID TO YOU AND I WILL
MAKE THIS COMMITMENT THAT I AM
PREPARED TO TO WORK WITH YOU
DURING THIS PROCESS AFTER IF
THIS BILL GETS OUT OF COMMITTEE.
OUGHT TO THINK OF WHAT THE
PROPORTIONAL --
SUGGESTION MIGHT BE AND HOW TO
HANDLE THESE FEES ARE BUT I JUST
THINK AT THIS POINT I IT'S THE
LITTLE BIT TO TO WORK THIS OUT
ON THE FLY WITH WHAT I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING IS A
DEADLINE OF WHEN.
ANOTHER BILL MIGHT ESET THESE
FEES SO WILL PASS WILL HAVE A
WAIVER UNTIL ANOTHER BILL COMES
ALONG THAT WOULD.
THAT WOULD WOULD RESET FEES AND
I I THINK IT'S BETTER TO JUST
HAVE THE CONVERSATION AT ONCE
AND WE DECIDE WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO MOVING FORWARD SO THAT'S
WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO ASK.
BOB BUT AGAIN HAPPY TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH YOU AND AND I'M NOT
SUGGESTING THAT IF THIS BILL
MOVES FOR OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
TODAY.
ARE WITH THE STATUS QUO LOW WITH
REGARDS TO FEES THAT OUT LATER
ON OF THE PROCESS WE CAN'T THAT
WE CAN ADDRESS.
BUT LET'S HAVE ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION MISTER GLORIA.
THANK YOU AS CHAIRMAN AND
SENATOR THANK YOU FOR OF THE
BILL TODAY --
I APPRECIATE THE EXCHANGE AND
OBVIOUSLY THE FOCUS ON THE ISSUE --
FOR THOSE OF YOU DON'T AYE
REPRESENTS EIGHTY EIGHT SO YOU
MIGHT UNDERSTAND MY POINT OF
VIEW ON THIS ISSUE A WHICH IS
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AND I FEEL THIS WAY BECAUSE MY
CITY CANNOT SOLVE THE STATE'S
HOUSING CRISIS.
AND SO IF YOU SEE A BONE OF
GRANNY FLAT SINCE WE'RE GOING
UNITS WAVE YOUR CALL --
IN MY SEE THAT IS NO WAY GOING
TO SOLVE THE POWER.
AND AS AN OUT PROUD YIN BE
ELECTED OFFICIAL --
I NEED MORE COMMITTEES DO THAT
BECAUSE MY FOLKS ARE WILLING TO
ENTERTAIN A MY ATTITUDES ON THIS
ISSUE I WITH THE EXPECTATION
THAT OTHERS WILL DO THEIR FAIR
SHARE -- AND
SO -- YOU
KNOW THIS IS REALLY TO MISINFORM
BY MY LOCALS A WHO LOOKED AT
THIS CLOSELY OF ASSISTING DAHLE
UNITS I THINK IN THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO OF THE FEES ASSOCIATED
WITH THEM WHERE CLOSE TO FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS BECAUSE THE
COUNCIL ACTION IT'S AS WELL AS I
THINK. EIGHT THOUSAND POINT IS
IS IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE I'VE
HEARD FROM CONSTITUENTS WHO
DON'T KNOW WHO BOB WHITE HOUSE
HE IS WE DON'T KNOW WHO S. B.
WHY S. B. EIGHT THIRTY ONE IS.
TELLING ME THEY NEED THE FEES
REDUCE FOR THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
DO THIS --
AND SO IT'S VERY ODD OR UNUSUAL
TO HAVE ORGANIC UNPROMPTED
CONVERSATION THE CONSTITUENT
ABOUT A POLICY IDEA BUT THIS IS
ONE OF THEM.
I WHEN I HEARD OF YOUR BILL I
THINK IT'S WORTHWHILE TO TO MOVE
THIS DIRECTION I SHARE THESE
FEELINGS WITH THE CHAIR --
MIND COLLEAGUES MAY REMEMBER MR
TEAMS BILL WAS HERE AND HAD A
PROVISION SUMMER THIS I'D
QUESTION WHY WAS REMOVED BECAUSE
I KNOW IT'S THAT.
A CRITICAL TO GO NO GO ON IF YOU
BELIEVE AS I DO THAT THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM FACING THE STATE IS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS THEN WE NEED TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
I'M I HEARD THAT THE SENATOR'S
COMMENTS AND I SEE THIS IS
DOUBLE REFERRED I THINK THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY TAKE THE
AMENDMENT THAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING
WHICH THINGS A REASONABLE SORT
OF HALF MEASURE --
TO YOU KNOW SORT OF SUSPEND THIS
FOR THE SHORT TERM UNTIL THE
STUDY COMES BACK --
I THINK I KNOW THAT I APPRECIATE
THE HONESTY OF IT TO TO KNOW
FEES -- BUT
YOU KNOW AS A FORMER CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER YOU KNOW THAT I
REALIZE HE'S HE'S A CRITICAL THE
BUILDING LIBRARIES ARE ACTUALLY
WHAT I'M EXISTING COMMUNITIES
MOSTLY -- TO
EXPANDING LIBRARIES IMPROVING
LIBRARIES FIRE STATIONS ACCEPT
IRA -- BUT
GUYS NO ONE DELIVER THESE
COMMUNITIES HAVE NOT AFFORDABLE
THERE'S NO PLACE FOR THEM TO
LIVE -- AND
I TEND TO AGREE WITH WHAT MR Y.
KOWSKI SAYING IN TERMS OF THE
ABILITY TO BRING THESE UNITS
INTO COMPLIANCE.
OBVIOUS OUT REASSESS THE
PROPERTIES OF FOR THEY WERE ALL
GOING PROPERTY TAXES WHICH THE
HECK OF A LOT MORE MONEY --
THEN DEVELOP A ONE TIME
DEVELOPER FEES SO I SUPPORT THIS
MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M I'M HAPPY TO
MOVE THE BILL AS IT'S CURRENTLY --
DE ENVISIONED OF NOT TO BE
PROVOCATIVE BUT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE'S ANOTHER STOP BEFORE
THE FLOOR THE ASSEMBLY AND THAT
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT I WOULD BE
A TWO OF PSYC TWO STOPS MY
APOLOGIES --
I CAN COUNT --
TO TO HAD THAT THERE'S ANOTHER
STOP ON THE WAY IN THIS CAN
ALLOW MORE CONVERSATION ABOUT AN
ISSUE THAT I THINK NEEDS TO BE
DISCUSSED BUT I MAKE THIS MOTION
ON BEHALF OF MY CONSTITUENTS WHO.
ARE TRYING TO DO THEIR VERY BEST
TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM BUT CAN DO
BY THEMSELVES THEY NEED THE
ENTIRE STATE MOVING IN THIS
DIRECTION.
ANY OTHER CONVERSATION
[inaudible]
BUT CHOI.
SENATOR LISTENING TO OUR THE
ARGUMENT DOUBLE ON FOR SIZE SO.
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED.
THEM MEETING IN THAT HAPPY
MEDIUM OCCUR HEAVY DISCOUNT.
IQS SO THAT DOT.
COM DEVELOP BUT IN A IMPACT FEE.
UP WE IMPACT THE A TWO COSTA TO
BE ARE SO HIGH INTO ELIMINATING
AND A LACK OF 50% 6% 80%
DISCOUNT THAT AND TO STEER.
US SOME REASONABLE RECHARGE IT
BE MADE TO US WITHOUT A THE
LOCAL AGENCIES WHO WOULD BE
HAPPY.
YES I HAVE ENTERTAIN THAT HEY WE
ARE WE DOCTOR CHOI CHU I HAVE
PROPOSED SOMETHING LIKE THAT TO
BE PROPORTIONAL I JUST I THINK
IT THIS TIME WITHOUT FURTHER
DATA -- TO
GO FROM WHAT IS BEING.
PAID FOR RIGHT NOW DOWN --
TO ZERO WITH ALL OF THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS THAT THIS BILL IS
REQUIRING IN ADDITION TO ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE PUT A LOCAL.
JURISDICTIONS AROUND EIGHTY
YEARS FEELS INCREDIBLY ONEROUS
SO I I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE MR
GLORIA'S POINTED I AGREE I THINK
THESE FEES.
VERY LIKELY NEED TO BE REDUCED
BUT I'M JUST NOT CERTAIN RIGHT
NOW IF IT NEEDS TO BE REDUCED
FROM A 100% DOWN.
TO ZERO AND AGAIN CITIES THAT
BELIEVE THAT.
AN AMNESTY MAKES SENSE CAN GO
FORWARD AND DO IT AND AND THAT'S
WHAT SAN DIEGO HAS DONE.
AND AND I ENCOURAGE OTHER CITIES
IF THEY CHOOSE TO DO THAT THAT
IS SOMETHING THEY CAN DO.
AS WELL BUT JUST TO HAVE THE
STATE TELL EVER IT SHOULD TELL
YOUR CITY OF IRVINE --
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU CAN'T COLLECT
FEES EVEN IF YOU'RE GONNA SPEND
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
IMPLEMENTING ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SACRAMENTO IS
ASKING YOU TO IMPLEMENT.
BOB THAT THAT JUST FEELS HONOR
SO WE HAD WE HAD OFFERED SOME
WHAT WE REFER TO AS MORE
PROPORTIONAL --
LANGUAGE TO TO TRY TO REDUCE THE
FEES WITHOUT ELIMINATING THE
FEES CENTER WHITE HOUSE GET ON A
FEW THOUGHTS ON ON THAT.
I'M WALLS SO WE'RE ALL CLEAR YOU
CAN STILL CHARGE PERMIT FEES YOU
CAN STILL CHARGE INSPECTION FEES
YOU CONSISTENT CHARGE THE IDEAS
THAT YOU CHARGE THAT WORK THAT
YOU HAVE TO DO IN OVER THE TIP
TO PROCESS THIS.
I'M YOU KNOW WE'VE.
THE IMPACT FEES ARE A A FLAT FEE
THAT THE CITY COULD HAVE ON THE
PARKS THAT THEY SAVED FOR FUTURE
PARK SERVE CURRENT PARKS IT'S
SEVEN GRAND IN ITS SEVEN GRANTS
WHICH FOURTEEN THOUSAND WE
ALLOWED.
THEM. TO TO PUT THAT IN I'M.
YOU KNOW THE BILL BEFORE YOU
WE'VE TAKEN OUT AT LEAST FOR A
FLAT FEE FOR THE SCHOOLS THAT IS
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS ARM YOU
KNOW WHEN I CAN I ASK WHERE THAT
WE WE'VE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
DISCERN WHERE THE THREE THOUSAND
ALL FLIGHT WAS TEMPERATURES.
ABOUT MCGWIRE'S --
HAVE GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE IN
THIS CENTURY WHAT'S IT BASED ON
I THINK IT IN THE LOCAL AREA HE
HAD -- NO
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WE SCHOOLS CANNOT
CHARGING IMPACT FEE FOR AN
EIGHTY YOU THAT'S FIVE HUNDRED
FEET OR LAST.
SO ALL THE ALL THE DISCUSSION
THAT WE'RE HAVING OF AT SCHOOL
IMPACTS IF IT'S FIVE INTERFERE
LESS IT'S NOTHING SO IT'S
BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED AND ABOVE
THEY CAN HAVE AN IMPACT HE SAID
THAT'S LIMITED.
AND MOST THAT THE GARAGE
CONVERSIONS ARE BETWEEN FOUR
FIFTY AND FIVE FIFTY SO YOU KNOW
THEY THAT THE WHAT YOU GET A
CATCHES ANOTHER FIFTY FEET IN
THE GARAGE CONVERSION SO.
RATHER THAN PALM.
QUIBBLE I I TOOK THE AMENDMENT
IT WAS ASKED UPON ME I THOUGHT
WHEN I WAS IN NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THAT CENTER SKINNER ABOUT.
CONSOLIDATING THE BILL'S WITH
HER SO I'M.
THAT I DON'T.
KNOW THAT IT'S SCIENTIFICALLY
DRAWN I CHAIR.
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW SCIENCE FAX
[inaudible]
THE I DATA.
THERE WAS ANOTHER QUESTION I
FORGOT IT'S I'M SORRY ANY OTHER
ANY OTHER DISK FOLLOW UP
QUESTION IS THAT DIE IF --
LEADS THIS HONUS AMNESTY PERIOD
THAT DIDN'T GIVE WHEN --
THAT SO THAT MEANS SAID THERE'LL
BE NO PENALTY FOR NOT HAVING.
REGISTERED DAHLE PAY CORRECTIVE
MEAN MY IN WHAT I ENVISIONED
UNDER THE AMNESTY PROGRAM IS
THAT THAT YOU WOULD FIRST YOU
HAVE TO PAY FOR THE INSPECTOR TO
COME OUT.
AND SECOND YOU HAVE TO PAY FOR
YOUR PERMIT FEE THAT'S THAT
THAT'S THAT'S NINE THIS
DISPUTABLE YOU COME IN THERE AND
THEN YOU HAVE TO PAY FOR WHAT.
WHATEVER THEY SAY HAS BEGUN TO
MAKE IT.
SAVE THAT NO I CENTER BATES HAS
A BILL THAT SAYS IF YOU LOOK AT
THE TIME WHEN IT WAS BUILT AND
IT WAS A BILL TO CODE AT THAT
TIME THE LANGUAGE HERE SAYS THAT
WE'RE GONNA GIVE YOU TEN YEARS.
TO BRING IT UP UP TO SAFETY THAT
IS MAKE IT THAT DETERMINATION BY
THE INSPECTOR THE IDEA AND THEN
THE IDEA WHEN YOU COUPLE THAT
WITHOUT THE FEES IS THAT PEOPLE
COME FORWARD.
PEOPLE MAKE THE A A IMPROVEMENTS
TO THE BAR THE HOME THEY START
PAYING THEIR PROPERTY TAXES ON
THAT GARAGE CONVERSION THE
ASSESSOR COMES IN IT AND THAT'S
THAT AND IN THE CITY OR THE
COUNTY.
THE IT I'LL YOU KNOW DOES THE
ARCHITECTURAL WOULD PUT
IMPROVEMENTS THAT THE CIVIL YOU
KNOW PUT A DOOR AND THERE WERE
MAKE IT LOOK NICER SO SO WE
INSTEAD OF SAYING YOU DO IT ALL
UP FRONT AT THE TIME WE GIVE
THEM A PERIOD.
BECAUSE I AYE IT BELIEVED THAT
THE M. FOR CLINTON MEAN THERE'S
TO BE A LOT OF PEOPLE THERE SOME
PEOPLE THAT ARE SAY HEY I
BOOTLEG THIS NOBODY KNOWS I
EXIST WHY MY GONNA COME IN AND
YOU KNOW LET THEM KNOW I'M.
LEGAL -- SO
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE PHILOSOPHY
OF OF GIVING THEM THAT TIME
PERIOD UNTIL IT WAS THE PROPERTY
TAX IT WOULD BE UP ON THEM FROM.
A THIS POINT ON NOT THE
TERMINATION OF THE PASSAGE E.
YEAH THAT WAS A MAIN.
YES THAT'S THAT'S THE BILL
BEFORE YOU IS THAT IT STARTS
WHEN THEY COME IN AND AGAIN THIS
IS A BIG PROBLEM OUT THERE THAT
THESE FOLKS ARE THERE AND IF I
IF I MADE THEM PAY THE
RETROACTIVE PROPERTY TAX NOBODY
COME FORWARD.
LA REGIS WOULD HIT SAY NO THAT'S
NOT THERE'S NO DEAL THERE --
SO.
NOW WITH THAT AN AMNESTY ARE
MOVING FOR THE FROM NOW ON RIGHT
NOW OR NOT BE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
IT OKAY.
SO ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION --
SO YOU KNOW AGAIN MY PERSPECTIVE
HE AYE I HEAR WHAT I THINK I'M.
HERE IS A DIFFERENT.
SUGGESTED AMENDMENT THAT SOMEHOW
THERE BE AN AMNESTY WHICH WOULD
APPLY FROM WHEN THIS BILL GOES
TO EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST TWO
WHEN THE REPORT.
GETS RESOLVED WHO WILLING AND WE
AND THEY RENEW YOUR INTO WE
CODIFY WHAT IT SO SO IN EUROPE
IT WHAT YOU'VE SAID TODAY IS
THAT IS IF THIS BILL BECAME LAW.
BEGINNING JANUARY ONE OF NEXT
YEAR THERE WOULD BE NO FEES THAT
PEOPLE COULD.
WHAT DID YOU MISS A PAL THESE
AND COUNTIES COULD A CHARGE THE
SCHOOLS WILL GET A THREE
THOUSAND DOLLAR THERE WOULD BE
AN AMNESTY PERIOD WHERE PEOPLE
WOULD COME IN AND SAY?
I WANT IT I WANTED --
I WANT TO COME LEGAL AND DO THIS
THEN WE WILL BE RACING THE CLOCK
WITH HDDS REPORT IF IT EIGHT CD
COMES UP WITH ITS REPORT ISSUE
SAID NEXT YEAR AND THERE'S
LEGISLATION THAT WE TAKE THAT
SAY.
THE EXCESS RECALLING UNITS SHALL
PAY. NINE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY AS A REASONABLE FEE FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT IMPACT THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE AND CITIES ARE ABLE
TO CHARGE THAT THEN JANUARY ONE
OF TWENTY TWENTY THAT WOULD BE.
WE AYE I'VE.
GOTTA GO TALK TO LEDGE COUNCIL
BUT THAT WOULD BE THE LAW THAT
WOULD THAT WITH THIS LITTLE
WINDOW WOULD GO AWAY AND IF IT
WAS. ZERO THEN IT WOULD SAY.
SO IF I CAN'T OF MY COMMITTEE
SEPARATE MY ME WE CAN'T TAKE
AMENDMENTS AT THIS POINT SITE
WOULD HAVE WHAT HE AND LOCAL GOV
SO WHAT I'M ASKING FOR YOU AT
THIS TIME IS --
AN AMENDMENT THAT WOULD REVERT
BACK PORTION SO RELATE NUMBER
TEN OF THE SIXTEEN THINGS --
BACK TO CURRENT LAW SORT SO IN
OTHER WORDS THAT WE NOT.
OR THAT THAT THAT WE NOT --
ADDRESS THIS FEE ISSUE HERE IF
YOU WANT TO HAVE FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS AFTER THIS
COMMITTEE ARE IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ON THIS I'M MORE THAN
WILLING TO ENTERTAIN IT I'M JUST
NOT WILLING TO SUPPORT THIS IDEA
IN PART BECAUSE I THINK THE IDEA
OF AN AMNESTY THAT START SHARING
Y..
SOME BEARD OF TIME MAYBE THROUGH
THE END OF THE YEAR --
IT PUTS YET ANOTHER PART OF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO FIGURE OUT
THE AMNESTY PIECE WHEN THEY MAY
HAVE TO REVERSE IT.
LITERALLY SOME MONTHS LATER AND
SO IT FIGURE THIS OUT ON THE FLY
JUST DON'T THINK ONE OF THE
ENTITIES PIANIST THESE
PRETENDERS THE PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
MC FOR TEN YEARS WHAT I WAS
SAYING WITH REGARD TO WHAT THE
FEEBLE CORRECT.
FIFTY THERE WOULD BE OBVIOUSLY
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE FEE IS
OUT THERE WOULD BE A A INCENTIVE
FOR PEOPLE TO COME OUT OF THE
DARK IF THEY KNEW THAT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE TO PAY AN IMPACT FEE.
A DEVELOPER IMPACT THE RAIN
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A FOR A FOLKS
WOULD GET THERE WELL.
WE CAN CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION I JUST THEM ASKING
FOR A COMMITMENT THAT WE RIVER
AT LEAST THIS SECTION BACK TO
CURRENT LAW.
YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT GREATS
RELUCTANTLY OKAY THANK YOU.
ARE WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
PROPOSE A DO PASS.
OUR EYES IT DEPENDS AS AMENDED.
WITH WITHOUT UP WITH THE WITH
THE AMENDMENT THAT WE JUST WITH
THE AMENDMENT WE JUST DESCRIBED
IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT ON THIS FEE
ISSUE.
AS THE PLAN IS THE BILL WAS
PRESENTED THAT'S THE MAP THAT'S
THE ONE AMENDMENT.
THERE'S NO THERE THERE I I DID
NOT ACCEPT THE OTHER AMENDMENT
THAT WAS OUTLINED IN THE STAFF
REPORT.
IT WILL CROSS [inaudible]
OKAY.
CENTER MIGHT MY STAFFER MONEY
THIS WOULD HAVE TO BE TAKEN AS
AN AUTHOR AMENDMENT NOT AS A
COMMITTEE MEMBER BECAUSE WE
OBVIOUSLY.
IT'S PROCEDURE SO RUSHING YOU TO
TAKE THE AMENDMENT THAT THAT
ISSUE ON FEES --
WHICH IS DESCRIBED IN.
SECTION ARE IN GOD NUMBER TEN OF
THE SUMMARY OF THIS THAT WE JUST
REFER BACK TO LOSS OF STRIKE
THAT PORTION.
AND THEN WE CAN LIVE TO
DISCUSSES ANOTHER DAY AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
I THOUGHT I HEARD YOU SAY THAT
YOU WOULD WANT THE AUTHOR TO
TAKE THAT WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT I WILL CONTINUE. TO TO WORK
WITH YOU SO FOR PURPOSES OF
TODAY I'M WILL HAVE THE AUTHOR
AMENDMENT BUT I STILL WANT TO
SEE IF I CAN CONVINCE YOU.
OF THAT THE GOOD THE BENEFITS
AND THE WISDOM OF HAVING AT
LEAST A SMALL WINDOW OF OF NO
PEACE OR LIMITED FEES THAT THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT MAY TAKE.
I WITH THAT I'M WILLING TO
UNWILLING TO ENGAGE IN THAT
CONVERSATION THAT COMMITMENT
BECAUSE I'VE HAD FOR
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IT BUT HAPPY
TO OF HAPPY TO ENGAGE AND AND
AND I WILL SAY TO THE PUBLIC WE
ARE LOOKING.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR SOME CREATIVE
IDEAS ON HOW TO ADDRESSES
BECAUSE ON THE ONE HAND I THINK
WE ALL AGREE THAT IF.
FEES IN A NUMBER OF
JURISDICTIONS ARE TOO HIGH EVEN
THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS CAN
CHOOSE TO ELIMINATE THEM ON THE
OTHER HAND.
BRING THEM DOWN --
TO ZERO FEELS A BIT ONEROUS AT A
TIME WHEN WE ARE LAYERING ON SO
MANY NEW REQUIREMENTS ON ATV SO
WITH THAT I THINK WE HAVE AN
AGREEMENT [inaudible]
OKAY -- OR
WITHOUT AND LESSER ANY FINAL
COMMENT MAKE IT JUICE
[inaudible]
WITH.
THE ROOM FILLED I AM.
IN MY HEART OF HEARTS BELIEVE
THAT THIS FEE THING IS THE LYNCH
PIN THAT'S GOING TO THAT'S
REALLY GOOD AND UNLEASH THE
HOUSING AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
OUR FIFTH MEETING. TO DISCUSS TO
DISCUSS THIS IS WHAT WAS
MEETINGS WITH OTHER --
FOLKS TO TO UNDERSCORE THAT EVEN
IF IT'S FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME I THINK IT'S GOOD IT THE
THE ADDRESSING THE HOUSING NEEDS
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA ARE
SO ACUTE.
THAT -- BUT
IT'S A LONG DAY SO.
EDU HAS IT IS WE'VE EPSOM SOME
SUCCESS AND MOVE THE WE ARE.
OKAY THERE'S BEEN A MOTION WITH
THE BILLS ARE SECOND.
I THINK MISTER COREY HAD WITH A
BILL PREVIOUSLY [inaudible]
SO.
SO THAT THERE THAT SO DOCTOR
CHOI HAS SECONDED THE MOTION
THAT WAS MADE BY MISTER GLORIA
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
CHIU AYE CHIU AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
ITEM EIGHT TWO S. B. EIGHT
THIRTY ONE NUMBER.
TWO MAIENSCHEIN NO CHAO.
CHOI HIGH CHOI AYE GLORIA GLORIA
AYE THE MONTHS.
WE MONTH I WOULD [inaudible]
WOULD I YOU BILLS OUT WE WAIT
FOR ADDITIONAL ADD ONS.
AND WITH THAT ONE WE GO BACK
THROUGH THE ROLE TO ADD ON
MISSING MEMBERS.
MADAM SECRETARY WHO START WITH
FILE ITEM.
ONE S. B. EIGHT TWENTY ONE I
SUPPORTER --
I KNOW ZERO WE COULD ADD ON
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS SHED.
MAIENSCHEIN.
FILE ITEM ONE FAVORITE MONEY
[inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN NO.
CHOI NO CHOI YOU KNOW.
WOULD OUT NOW WOULD.
IT CAN --
FOR TO DO.
A CHILLING RAIN CHANCES ARE THAT
BILLS OUT --
FOR TWO SAND Y. CASKETS BILL I
THINK EVERYONE HERE HAS VOTED ON
IT.
OUT SIR BATES BILL FILING --
THREE S. B. --
TWELVE TWENTY SIX ICE FIVE THE
SEER A NO ZERO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I CHOI.
CHOI AYE THAT THOSE OUT SEVEN
ZERO FALLEN FOR S. B. TWELVE
SIXTY FIVE WHITE HUSKY.
THAT BOAT CURLEY'S THREE ONE
NIELSEN NUMBERS.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NO
GLORIA GLORIA I WOULD
[inaudible]
WHAT I?
THE BILLS OUT FIVE TWO AND FINAL
AND FILE ITEM FIVE SP FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN MCGUIRE.
AND HE SAID I CITY ARE NO ZEROS
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE CHAU.
GLORIA.
GLORIA I WOULD [inaudible]
WOULD I THAT BILLS OUT I THINK
WE HAVE ONE MORE MEMBER WE ARE
WAITING FOR TO COME BACK --
WE WILL ADJOURN AT THAT TIME HOW
[inaudible]
LONG AGO [inaudible]
IT WAS [inaudible]
PROBABLY.
SOME OF THE COMPLETELY.
AND GET IT REPORTING APPROACH
AFTER THE MARKETS LIKE.
SO.
WE'RE GONNA JUST ABOUT
[inaudible]
YEAH
GET OUT ON MISTER CHAO TO
HIS FINAL BILLS OR THE VOTE SAID
HE WAS NOT ABLE.
TO TAKE.
I AM COULD BE ANYONE.
HE SAID.
NINE CHALLENGES THE KNOW
MACASSAR Y. CASKETS S. B. EIGHT
THIRTY ONE WHICH WAS THE LAST
ITEM WE DISCUSSED --
SIX ONE THAT BILLS OUT. FIVE
SPEAK WORKING.
CHOW CHOW CHOW I AND DOES THAT
BILL GETS OUT SEVEN SIR